Willie, what kind of shirt you have on?
What is that?
It's cotton.
Are you familiar?
It's a thing.
It's a rooster.
Willie，你穿的是什么衬衫？那是什么？是棉的。是棉的。你熟悉吗？你熟悉吗？那是个东西。是个公鸡。
It's a, well, no, it's a Liverpool football club.
Oh, what is mine saying?
Yeah.
And yours says, out of office.
Where did you get that particular freebie?
I used to work at that.
Listen, I can't wait to hear this, but let's do it all those Smartless first.
那是，嗯，不，那是利物浦足球俱乐部的。哦，我的写的是什么？对。你的写的是“不在办公室”。对。你从哪弄到那个特别的赠品的？我以前在那儿工作过。听着，我迫不及待想听这个，但我们先做完Smartless的开场吧。
Welcome to Smartless.
Sweet, Sweet Willie is over on the pond.
Across the pond.
Across the pond, I'm in Liverpool.
Wait, why are you there?
My home away from home.
I'm doing a little thing with the club.
Oh, I didn't know that.
欢迎来到Smartless。甜蜜的威利在池塘那边。在池塘那边。在池塘那边，我在利物浦。等等，你为什么在那儿？我的第二个家。我正在和俱乐部做点小事。哦，我不知道。
With our friends at Tommy Hilfiger.
Shout out Tommy Hilfiger.
There it is.
We've got it.
Was it ever Thomas?
When did he go shorter with it?
Have you asked him?
I haven't asked him.
和我们的朋友Tommy Hilfiger一起。向Tommy Hilfiger致敬。就是这样。我们搞定了。它曾经叫Thomas吗？他什么时候把它改短了？你问过他吗？我没问过他。
I'm going to have dinner with him later.
Well, sounds like a perfect opportunity.
Which is what it's going to be.
And yeah.
So, Shawnee, you're back in Los Angeles.
Oh, God, yeah.
After an incredible, successful run.
What a run.
我待会儿要和他共进晚餐。嗯，听起来是个绝佳的机会。这正是它将要成为的样子。是的。所以，肖尼，你回到洛杉矶了。哦，天哪，是的。在一段令人难以置信的成功演出之后。多么棒的演出。
He's got himself an Olivier Award already from this thing.
We will see what our friends over at the Tony Academy.
No, no, no, no, no, no, Jay.
The Olivier's from Good Night Oscar.
Oh, the Olivier was for a good night Oscar.
Did you win an Olivia?
Yeah, he sure did.
多么棒的演出。他已经凭这个拿到了奥利弗奖。我们将看看我们在托尼奖学院的朋友们怎么说。不，不，不，不，不，不，杰。奥利弗奖是《晚安，奥斯卡》的。哦，奥利弗奖是给《晚安，奥斯卡》的。你赢了奥利弗奖吗？是的，他确实赢了。
No way.
Yeah, is that crazy?
But, Shawnee, yeah, so we haven't started the award circuit yet for...
No, the unknown.
It's called the unknown.
But you can't because it's off-Broadway.
So, I mean...
Off-Broadway has no awards?
不会吧。是的，那不是很疯狂吗？但是，肖尼，是的，我们还没有开始颁奖季，因为……不，那个未知的。它叫《未知》。但你不能，因为它是外百老汇的。所以，我的意思是……外百老汇没有奖项吗？
It does.
And I got nominated for the one that they do.
It's called the...
I forget what it's called, but...
Is it called off Tony?
It was very nice.
It's off-tony, yeah.
Are they called the Tinnies?
有的。我被提名为他们举办的那个奖项了。它叫……我忘了它叫什么，但是……它叫外百老汇托尼奖吗？它非常好。是外百老汇托尼奖，是的。它们叫“小托尼奖”吗？
The Tannies.
And let me ask you a question.
If you're off Broadway,
do you need to go backstage
and say hi to people?
No, you do not.
You do not have to do that.
But Sam Rockwell, your ears must have been burning.
“小托尼奖”。让我问你一个问题。如果你在外百老汇演出，你需要去后台和人们打招呼吗？不，你不需要。你不需要那样做。但是山姆·洛克威尔，你的耳朵一定在发烧。
Sam came backstage.
I know you're working with him.
He's so nice.
He's the best.
He's so sweet, yeah.
And, yeah, I just got back two nights ago.
It was great.
And by the way, you know, the adrenaline dump, right?
山姆来后台了。我知道你在和他合作。他太好了。他是最棒的。他太贴心了，是的。而且，是的，我两天前刚回来。太棒了。顺便说一句，你知道，肾上腺素消退，对吧？
Don't you guys feel that after you do a movie
or a TV show or play or anything like that?
When you're done, you're just like, oh, man.
And usually you get sick because the body knows it's now I can be ill.
Right.
But you came back and did you, what was your illness?
Just basic nausea from all the saturated fats that you.
I ate so much.
你们在拍完电影、电视节目或戏剧之类的东西后，难道没有这种感觉吗？当你完成时，你就像，哦，天哪。通常你会生病，因为身体知道现在我可以生病了。对。但你回来后，你得了什么病？只是因为你摄入的所有饱和脂肪而导致的轻微恶心。我吃得太多了。
On the plane back, I had ordered everything that I could.
I had.
You order food on the plane?
Yeah, all the time.
Yeah.
This is it like a menu?
Yes.
在回来的飞机上，我点了所有我能点的东西。我点了。你在飞机上点餐？是的，一直都点。是的。这就像菜单吗？是的。是的。
I'll have that.
I had the chicken, the beef,
I had a hot-fetched sundae.
You can't order two entrees on a flight.
You did.
And I had like three pretzel roll.
I was so hungry because I hadn't eaten
in three months because of the play.
我要那个。我吃了鸡肉、牛肉，我还吃了热软糖圣代。你不能在航班上点两份主菜。你点了。我还吃了三个椒盐卷饼。我太饿了，因为演戏期间我三个月没怎么吃东西。
I lost all that weight.
Anyway, who cares?
Wait, why didn't you eat during the play?
Because it's the whole thing I told you.
You have to watch what you eat, when you eat,
and you can't eat before a show
because of acid reflux and then you can't talk
because then you're constantly clearing your throat.
我减掉了所有那些体重。总之，谁在乎呢？等等，为什么演戏期间你不吃东西？因为我告诉过你，那是一整套流程。你必须注意你吃什么，什么时候吃，而且演出前不能吃东西，因为会胃酸倒流，然后你就不能说话了，因为你会不停地清嗓子。
It's just something like the whole thing.
Well, where does spaghetti bolognets with the side of,
Swedish fish fit in.
So that came, that comes after.
Got it.
After when I get home, after like, I texted you guys, a two-show day.
I'm like, oh, we know.
No, we saw the pigs, man.
这就像是整个流程的一部分。那么，意大利肉酱面配瑞典鱼软糖是怎么回事呢？那是后来，那是后来才吃的。明白了。回家之后，就像我给你们发短信说的那样，一天两场演出。我说，哦，我们知道。不，我们看到那些猪了，伙计。
You don't think the acid reflux would come from a midnight bowl of Bolognese?
No, because I stay up long enough for it to not happen.
Six or seven hours.
No.
Stay up.
It's not like you're going for a walk.
When you say stay up, you're just sitting on the couch and just letting it sit.
This is correct.
你不觉得胃酸倒流会来自午夜的一碗肉酱面吗？不，因为我熬得够晚，所以不会发生。六七个小时。不。熬夜。这又不是去散步。当你说是熬夜时，你只是坐在沙发上让它消化。这是正确的。
Why don't you sleep?
in an upright position.
That way you can just eat,
eat, eat until the last possible moment.
I do sometimes.
You ought to get like a,
you ought to get like a sleepable turlet,
这是正确的。你为什么不睡觉？以直立姿势。这样你就可以一直吃，一直吃，直到最后一刻。我有时会这样。你应该弄个，你应该弄个可以睡觉的马桶，
you know what I mean?
That has,
like, thing and that you could be.
Yeah, remember how like in Clockwork Orange,
he had his eyelids taped open?
Yeah, maybe you do that with your valve, you know?
Just a tube right in there with Polonaise.
And just go right to sleep.
你知道我的意思吗？它有那个东西，然后你可以……是的，记得《发条橙》里他怎么把眼皮粘住吗？是的，也许你可以对你的阀门那样做，你知道吗？直接插根管子进去，连着肉酱面。然后直接睡觉。
Guys, my guest today.
What are you just throwing?
Throw it in the toilet and cut out the middleman.
Throw it in the toilet.
I hope your guest understands your dark, dark, offensive humor.
He loves it, actually, which is good.
My guest couldn't speak until he was almost four years old.
We're going to learn about that.
伙计们，我今天的嘉宾。你到底在扔什么？扔进马桶里，省去中间商。扔进马桶里。我希望你的嘉宾能理解你那种黑暗、黑暗、冒犯性的幽默。他其实很喜欢，这很好。我的嘉宾直到快四岁时才开口说话。我们要了解一下。
When he finally did, he says he sounded like a member of the soprano family.
His mom was chief medical officer at the New York City Fire Department.
She survived the collapse of the South Tower on September 11th.
Oh, my God.
He once went through 12 dumpsters looking for his wife.
lost engagement ring.
They named their son Cosmo.
He co-owns a decommissioned
当他终于开口时，他说他听起来像黑道家族的一员。他妈妈是纽约消防局的首席医疗官。她在9月11日南塔倒塌中幸存下来。哦，天哪。他曾经翻过12个垃圾桶寻找他妻子的订婚戒指。他们给儿子取名科斯莫。他共同拥有一艘退役的
Staten Island Ferry,
which he has called the single dumbest person of his life.
Please welcome the longest-serving weekend update anchor
in Saturday Night Live history.
It's the hilarious and charming Colin Jones.
I think I got it first.
Colin Joseph for a few of yourself.
Michael Chee, what's up? Michael Chee here.
斯塔滕岛渡轮，他称之为他一生中最愚蠢的决定。请欢迎《周六夜现场》历史上任职时间最长的“周末更新”主播。他就是风趣迷人的科林·约斯特。我想我先拿到了。科林·约斯特，自我介绍一下。迈克尔·切，怎么了？迈克尔·切在此。
Hey, how's it going, guys?
What is up?
Guys, that was really, I loved hearing
that you guys.
Run down?
That can't be true.
嘿，伙计们，怎么样？怎么了？怎么了？伙计们，那真的，我喜欢听你们说的。总结？那不可能是真的。那不可能是真的。
I learned a lot about you guys.
Oh, you're, by the way,
all of it's unsurprising.
You're in your office right now,
I can tell by the ceiling.
Yeah.
Is that true?
Yes, these definitely asbestos ceilings
我从你们身上学到了很多。哦，顺便说一句，这一切都不令人惊讶。你现在在你的办公室里，我从天花板就能看出来。是的。是真的吗？是的，这些绝对是石棉天花板，
that are still here.
Those are the kind of ceilings
that you can stand on a chair,
lift up one of them,
and hide stuff up there,
put the square right back down.
Definitely.
You could have, that's no country for old men.
还留在这里。那种天花板，你可以站在椅子上，掀开一块，把东西藏在上面，再把方块放回去。绝对可以。你可以，那简直是《老无所依》。
This one you see has a large stain
of some kind that's been here
since before I moved in.
Yeah, something up there is leaking that was hidden.
They came to the SNL offices like five years ago,
and they said, listen, over the summer,
you got to clear stuff out.
We're removing asbestos from all the offices.
你看到的这一块有一大块污渍，在我搬进来之前就在这儿了。是的，上面有什么东西在漏水，被藏起来了。他们大约五年前来到SNL办公室，说，听着，夏天的时候，你们得把东西清理干净。我们要拆除所有办公室的石棉。
And I was like, I've been in this office for 15 years.
No way.
Too late.
Really?
Yeah.
They just found that out of it.
You ought to call one of the, you know,
those commercials that come on late at night with those doctor.
我说，我在这个办公室待了15年了。不会吧。太晚了。真的吗？是的。他们才发现。你应该打给那些，你知道的，深夜播出的那些医生广告。
You should join a class action.
I mean, well, I have that,
and I've got my vaginal mesh that I've got.
got to haul about too.
No, no.
Yeah, what's the
progress on that?
Good.
你应该加入集体诉讼。我的意思是，我有那个，我还有我的阴道网片，我也得处理一下。不，不。是的，那个进展如何？很好。
The mesh is separating?
Yeah, the mesh is
it sounded great at the time, you know?
He's like, you want to do this vaginal mess.
It sounds so cool, but then.
Right, of course.
Yeah.
Tell me, what is,
网片在分离吗？是的，网片，当时听起来很棒，你知道吗？他说，你想做这个阴道网片吗？听起来很酷，但后来。对，当然。是的。告诉我，什么是，
just by the way, what is vaginal mesh?
Yeah, by the way, I wanted to ask
too, but I was afraid I didn't know.
By the way, just get more serious.
Get more serious on the question.
Well, I did want to get back to the asbestos.
and I wanted to pitch Colin,
because I think I've pitched you guys before,
顺便问一下，什么是阴道网片？是的，顺便说一句，我也想问，但我怕我不知道。顺便说一句，严肃点。问题严肃点。好吧，我确实想回到石棉的话题，我想向科林推销，因为我想我之前向你们推销过，
and I don't remember your response,
but Colin, could you please,
let me know if you think this.
I'm thinking about getting into a mold removal business
based on just the company name that I've got nailed down.
It's called adjacent abatement.
And I think I could just go into that business.
I'll do pretty well just based on the title and just fans.
我不记得你们的反应了，但科林，你能告诉我你觉得这个怎么样吗？我正在考虑进入除霉业务，就凭我定下的公司名字。它叫“邻近减排”（Adjacent Abatement）。我觉得我只要进入那个行业就行了。光凭这个名字和粉丝，我就能做得很好。
Just the joke.
The joke alone.
The paint on the side of the vans, the bus benches, stuff like that.
I'm pretty sure I'll get some nice traffic.
Oh, when people have extensive mold in their house, they just want to laugh.
They want to know they can laugh.
They're looking for a pun.
Honey, I hope we find some mold because I just want to call it Jason abatement.
光是这个笑话。光是这个笑话。货车侧面的喷漆，公交车站的长椅，诸如此类的东西。我很确定我会得到不错的流量。哦，当人们家里有大面积霉菌时，他们只想笑。他们想知道他们可以笑。他们在寻找双关语。亲爱的，我希望我们能发现一些霉菌，因为我只想叫它“邻近减排”。
That's good.
By the way, I've never heard that.
It's pretty good, right?
Colin, thanks so much for doing this.
You're being here.
Thanks for having me.
Colin, they're busy.
What is it?
那很好。顺便说一句，我从没听过这个。挺好的，对吧？科林，非常感谢你做这件事。你在这里。谢谢你们邀请我。科林，他们很忙。是什么？
This is a busy time for you.
We're off.
We're off this week.
I just came here because I was doing something nearby,
and it seemed like a good place to...
It's so quiet here.
Well, that doesn't sound shady, doing something nearby.
I was doing something nearby.
这对你来说是个忙碌的时期。我们这周休息。我来这儿是因为我刚好在附近做点事，这看起来是个好地方……这儿太安静了。嗯，这听起来不太正当，在附近做点事。我是在附近做点事。
Edit that out.
Are you bugging Lauren's office again?
Not in a way he would suspect.
Have you seen the new Lauren documentary?
I did.
We went to the, I guess, premiere of it
that was at Lincoln Center last week.
And have you guys seen it yet?
把那段剪掉。你又在窃听洛恩的办公室了吗？不是他会怀疑的那种方式。你看过新的洛恩纪录片了吗？看了。我们去了上周在林肯中心举行的首映式。你们看了吗？
No, I want to.
It was funny.
There's a lot of people in it are really funny.
And I found it kind of moving.
I don't know that I even necessarily learned anything about him.
In fact, in some ways, he seems less known having seen it.
But it was, I found it kind of moving because he is very much him.
And it felt like it was in his voice weirdly.
没有，我想看。很有趣。里面很多人真的很有趣。我觉得它有点感人。我不知道我是否真的了解了他什么。事实上，在某些方面，看完之后他似乎更神秘了。但它，我觉得它有点感人，因为他非常像他自己。奇怪的是，感觉就像是在用他的声音说话。
I don't know.
Yeah.
I love that he finally allowed someone.
to like kind of dig in right yeah i don't i think the thing that people don't know about
loren and you can attest to this uh colin is that uh lauren's really funny yeah he's he's
he's very dry really really funny yeah yeah and he is he is funny in it like he's funny in it but but
he'll you know someone will be talking about an idea on a whatever friday night and
pitch something and he'll just look at them and be like idiot
我不知道。是的。我喜欢他终于允许某人深入挖掘，对，是的，我不认为人们对洛恩了解的一点是，你可以证明这一点，呃，科林，那就是，洛恩真的很有趣，是的，他非常冷幽默，真的很有趣，是的，是的，他在里面很有趣，就像他在里面很有趣，但他会，你知道，有人会在周五晚上谈论一个想法，提出一些建议，他只会看着他们说，白痴。
He'll do things that are very out of character
And always very surprising and funny
But it is, he's funny in it
And he lets them go to
Like his house in Amaganza
His house in Maine
And you see like, not like all the inside of the house
But like you see where why he goes to those places
他会做一些非常不符合他性格的事情，而且总是非常令人惊讶和有趣，但确实，他在里面很有趣，他让他们去他的房子，比如他在阿马甘塞特的房子，他在缅因州的房子，你看到，不是看到房子的内部，而是看到他为什么去那些地方，
To kind of escape and be in the woods and be in age
It's I didn't I was surprised at that
Yeah he seems very kind of
When I worked there, when I did the show, I think 83 years ago,
he was always a little, he's scary if you don't know him, you know,
because he's a little off-putting.
Like, he doesn't speak much, so you don't know where you stand with him.
At least that was my.
去逃避，去树林里，去……我当时很惊讶。是的，他看起来非常……当我还在那儿工作，做那个节目时，我想是83年前，他总是有点，如果你不了解他，他很吓人，你知道，因为他有点拒人于千里之外。就像，他不怎么说话，所以你不知道你在他心里的位置。至少那是我的……
Yeah, he's kind of, yeah, he's kind of reserved until.
What if Colin's just like, what are you talking about?
He talks to everybody.
He's not.
Did he not talk to him?
He's like the most outgoing guy.
Huh, he's like one of those ton of jokes and that's happening.
You got to slow him down.
是的，他有点，是的，他有点矜持，直到……如果科林只是说，你在说什么？他跟每个人都说话。他不是。他没跟他说话吗？他就像那种最外向的人。哈，他就像那种有很多笑话的人，事情正在发生。你得让他慢下来。
Colin, I think the first time we ever met was only last year at Robert Downey's birthday party, right?
I think.
Yeah, I think so.
And you were so kind enough if you remember this.
You mailed me the form that you have to fill out to get a face mold on Saturday Night Live.
You mailed it.
Do you remember mailing that to me?
For Louie to get it to do with Louis?
科林，我想我们第一次见面是在去年罗伯特·唐尼的生日派对上，对吧？我想是。是的，我想是。你当时非常友善，如果你还记得的话。你寄给我那份你在《周六夜现场》做面部模具需要填写的表格。你寄给我的。你记得寄给我吗？为了让路易去做？
I don't know, but it was like a format with my Polaroid on it and all my measurements and my head measurements.
to get like a mold.
And you just sent it to me.
I was like, oh, that's so nice.
I happened to, yeah, like, see, you know,
I think Jody, who does all the wigs and Louie does,
I think they had all these things
and they were kind of getting rid of them.
我不知道，但那就像是一个表格，上面有我的宝丽来照片，还有我所有的测量数据，我的头部测量数据。为了做一个模具。你只是把它寄给了我。我说，哦，那太好了。我碰巧，是的，就像，看到，你知道，我想乔迪，负责所有假发的人，还有路易，我想他们有所有这些东西，他们有点想处理掉它们。
And I was like, wait, some of these are,
they'd be cool.
Like, they're also, some of them are historic and everything.
It would be cool.
Yeah, it's cool.
It's like a cool memento to have.
Did you, did you go ahead and get the face mold measurement, Sean?
Yeah.
我说，等等，其中一些很酷。就像，它们也是，其中一些具有历史意义之类的。那会很酷。是的，很酷。这就像一个很酷的纪念品。肖恩，你真的去做了面部模具测量吗？是的。
And did you have a couple of spares made up?
Of my face?
Uh-huh.
Just walking through why...
Could we...
Let me ask you this.
Could Jason and I make masks and go as you for Halloween?
Or if you wanted to scare the shit out of...
你还做了几个备用的吗？我的脸？嗯哼。只是走过为什么……我们可以……让我问你这个。杰森和我可以做面具，万圣节扮成你吗？或者如果你想吓死……
We're just target practice and stuff like that.
Why were you excited about pursuing a face mold?
Well, you have to.
You did it.
You supposed to stand out there.
Didn't you get a face mold?
I don't remember.
And I don't think that I would track down the information on how to get one.
我们只是靶子练习之类的。你为什么对追求面部模具感到兴奋？好吧，你必须这样做。你做了。你应该站在那里。你没做面部模具吗？我不记得了。而且我不认为我会自己去追踪如何获得一个的信息。
myself.
It's a horrible process.
It's so indignant.
It's unbelievable.
I don't know what goes.
I'll go there with you and Scotty.
You probably did it and you probably blocked it out because you get, you can't breathe,
you know, you're breathing through just straws in your nose because your mouth has to stay
我自己。这是一个可怕的过程。太屈辱了。简直难以置信。我不知道发生了什么。我会和你还有斯科蒂一起去。你可能做了，你可能把它屏蔽了，因为你，你不能呼吸，你知道，你只能通过鼻子里的吸管呼吸，因为你的嘴必须保持
steady.
Yeah, yeah.
And it's very claustrophobic.
But did Sean, did you get, did you got information from Colin about how you can go ahead
and get another face mold of yourself or?
Yeah, well, all that information is on the form that.
that they make for you.
Yeah.
稳定。是的，是的。而且非常幽闭恐惧。但是肖恩，你从科林那里得到了关于你如何去再做一个面部模具的信息了吗？是的，好吧，所有这些信息都在他们为你制作的表格上。是的。
Right.
So now I have it.
Anyway, let's move on.
No, we're not going to.
Now you have it, and that's a great thing?
Yeah.
Yeah, why not?
Just in case you might want to make a face mold of yourself.
对。所以现在我有它了。总之，让我们继续。不，我们不会。现在你有了它，那是一件好事吗？是的。是的，为什么不呢？以防万一你想给自己做一个面部模具。
Unless my head is shrunk or grown or something.
It should be the same, right, Colin?
Oh, man.
You've got to get a new model every five years.
By the way, by the way, right, Colin?
Like, as if Colin fucking knows Andrew gives a shit about how this process.
He keeps dabs out.
He just found a piece of paper
除非我的头缩水了或者长大了之类的。应该是一样的，对吧，科林？哦，伙计。你每五年得换一个模型。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，对吧，科林？好像科林他妈的知道安德鲁在乎这个过程一样。他只是把东西拿出来。他只是找到了一张纸，
and he was like, here's the person that you should talk to.
He's not invested.
No, no. Then I went back to the files.
I compared, I was like, well, these measurements
are a little off from the last time.
That's what I'm saying.
All right.
他说，这是你应该联系的人。他没投入。不，不。然后我回到档案里。我比较了一下，我说，嗯，这些测量数据和上次有点出入。这就是我说的。这就是我说的。好吧。
You know the famous thing about Jeff Daniels got it done, right?
When he was hosting.
No, well.
And they set the mold in the wrong way.
So it stuck fully to his face.
And he was stuck with just the straws and his nose
for like hours and they had to chisel it off of him
and he had like all this sort of scarring,
你知道杰夫·丹尼尔斯做这件事的著名故事吗，对吧？当他主持的时候。不，好吧。他们把模具放错了位置。所以它完全粘在了他的脸上。他被困住了，只有鼻子里的吸管，持续了几个小时，他们不得不把它凿下来，他身上有所有那种疤痕，
not scarring but like almost burns from it
and then had to host the show.
No way.
Yeah.
That's a night, that's a fucking nightmare, man.
You could still, you could still sip Coca-Cola through,
like he could still drink something.
Oh yeah, so he was fine.
不是疤痕，而是像烧伤一样，然后还得主持节目。不会吧。是的。那是一场噩梦，伙计。你仍然可以，你仍然可以通过吸管喝可乐，就像他仍然可以喝东西一样。哦，是的，所以他没事。
But yeah, don't worry, Sean.
You can still have your sugar sodas, Sean.
Yeah.
Does anybody ever put Swedish fish in a blender?
What's your go-to tackiest awful snack, Colin?
What do you, what are you ashamed that you still eat?
You look like you keep it pretty tight.
I'm fine.
但是，别担心，肖恩。你仍然可以喝你的含糖汽水，肖恩。是的。有人把瑞典鱼软糖放进搅拌机里吗？科林，你最俗气、最糟糕的零食是什么？你有什么仍然在吃但感到羞耻的东西吗？你看上去保持得很好。我很好。
I don't eat great.
Like I don't have any discipline to eating and drinking,
but I'll eat Swedish fish actually at SNL
because there's like a pot.
Every Tuesday when there was a writing night,
they used to come in when you're up all night
and just pour a pile of candy,
like cover the entire writer's room in candy.
我吃得不好。我吃喝方面没有任何纪律，但我确实会在SNL吃瑞典鱼软糖，因为那里有一个罐子。每个周二，当有写作之夜时，他们过去常在你们通宵工作时进来，倒出一堆糖果，就像把整个编剧室都覆盖在糖果里一样。
And so I would have all Tuesdays I used to, you know, eat candy all the time.
And then being up all night,
there was one time in Lauren's office Wednesday after the table read
where I was having like heart palpitations.
I have that in my notes.
And I thought I was having a heart attack.
Yeah, I thought that was from stress or something.
It was a combination of stress, not sleeping,
所以我过去常在周二，你知道，一直吃糖果。然后通宵工作，有一次在周三的剧本朗读会后，在洛恩的办公室里，我心悸了。我的笔记里有这个。我以为我心脏病发作了。是的，我以为那是压力之类的。那是压力、不睡觉的结合，
and also having all the sugar.
And I thought I was having a heart attack.
and like called the doctor in Lauren's office.
Was it, was it a-fib, do you know?
Paddles wants to know what it was.
Well, Jimmy Kimmel calls me paddles
because I've had so much a-fib so many times.
It was not, it was not a, it was just a, yeah,
还有吃了所有的糖。我以为我心脏病发作了。就像在洛恩的办公室里叫医生。是房颤吗，你知道吗？帕德尔斯想知道那是什么。好吧，吉米·坎摩尔叫我帕德尔斯，因为我得过很多次房颤。那不是，那不是，那只是一个，是的，
it was like probably a panic attack, essentially,
that was brought on by.
Okay.
But you haven't had one since.
No, and the doctor I went to is like,
you gotta try to sleep a little,
and you got to, you can't have.
have sugar all night like that or, you know, I was like, whatever.
那可能是一次恐慌发作，本质上是由……引起的。好吧。但你之后没再发作过。没有，我去看的那位医生说，你得试着睡一会儿，你得，你不能。整晚吃糖之类的，或者，你知道，我说，随便吧。
Sugar doesn't make you, sugar makes me so tired that, that sugar peak and then the crash,
I go right to sleep.
Doesn't affect me.
I can run or sleep.
It doesn't matter.
Here we go.
But it was just in an age where I was like, it didn't matter.
And then it caught up with me at some point.
糖不会让你，糖让我很累，那个糖分高峰然后崩溃，我直接就睡着了。不影响我。我可以跑步或睡觉。没关系。我们开始吧。但这只是在一个我当时觉得没关系的年纪。然后它在某个时候追上了我。
I was like, oh.
Colin, wait, talk to me about this.
I found this fascinating.
What do you mean you didn't talk to you were four years old?
What does that mean?
And then I read that it wasn't Tony Soprano that you sounded like.
Like, because I was like, oh, he must have compared himself to Tony Sopranon when he opened up his mouth.
But what do you mean you didn't talk?
我说，哦。科林，等等，跟我谈谈这个。我觉得这很迷人。你四岁时没说话是什么意思？那是什么意思？然后我读到你听起来不像托尼·索普拉诺。因为我当时想，哦，他一定是在开口时把自己比作托尼·索普拉诺。但你没说话是什么意思？
No, I said Carmela, Sabrina.
Oh, Carmela.
That's right. Caramella.
Like, I was, there's videos in me like trying to, like, sell a bike that I had.
It's like, yeah, it's pretty good.
It's got two wheels.
You know, you can get on.
It's got brakes.
不，我说的是卡梅拉，萨布丽娜。哦，卡梅拉。对了。卡梅拉。就像，我当时，有我的视频，就像试图卖掉我的一辆自行车。就像，是的，它挺好的。它有两个轮子。你知道，你可以上去。它有刹车。
But I'm genuinely talking like that, and I'm six.
Really?
Seven.
Yeah.
When does a kid usually talk?
I forget with my kids.
It was like, like, one or like 18 months, something like that?
I think it's typically like, yeah, 18 months around that.
但我真的那样说话，我当时六岁。真的？七岁。是的。孩子通常什么时候说话？我忘了我的孩子了。是像一岁还是18个月左右？我想通常是，是的，18个月左右。
And I think it's almost always before two or usually.
Girls before guys, I think.
Yes, yeah.
And there's people are a little later,
but I think it was just getting to a little bit of a more extreme place
where they didn't know what was going on, my parents.
What were your first words?
Will.
而且我想几乎总是在两岁之前，或者通常是这样。女孩比男孩早，我想。是的，是的。有些人晚一点，但我认为这只是到了一个更极端的地方，他们不知道发生了什么，我的父母。你的第一句话是什么？威利。
No shit.
Yeah, I'm not just saying that.
I mean, I know.
Of course, I believe, I'm looking at your face and I know that you're not.
You're saying that.
That's incredible.
And that's it.
And then I didn't say anything else for five more years.
别开玩笑了。是的，我不是随便说的。我的意思是，我知道。当然，我相信，我看着你的脸，我知道你不是。你在说那个。那太不可思议了。就是这样。然后我五年没再说任何话。
Why bother?
You said it all.
And then it was Jason.
Jason abatement.
Because there had been so much mold in my brain.
So I needed.
何必呢？何必呢？你已经说完了。然后是杰森。杰森·阿贝特门特（Jason Abatement）。因为我的大脑里有太多的霉菌。所以我需要。
And there was nothing.
They didn't pursue any sort of reason.
There was no diagnosis.
It was just you just weren't ready.
Something.
And yeah, my mom said she wasn't worried.
because it seemed like I was comprehending everything
that they were saying.
而且什么都没有。他们没有追求任何理由。没有诊断。只是你还没准备好。什么之类的。而且是的，我妈妈说她不担心。因为看起来我理解他们说的每一句话。
I just wasn't saying anything.
And then I went to like a speech specialist
at Staten Island University Hospital,
which maybe sounds like a setup for a joke.
I mean, you do your own?
Everybody could do their own math on that one.
I like the idea you were just nodding along,
you were nodding on and doing a lot of winking.
我只是什么都没说。然后我去了斯塔滕岛大学医院的语言专家那里，这听起来可能像是一个笑话的铺垫。我的意思是，你自己做？每个人都可以自己算算那个。我喜欢你只是点头，你点头并眨了很多眼。
He was winking a lot of people.
So he knew he was cool.
We knew he was cool.
Oh, Doctor, no, he's following.
He was winking and doing the hands where he makes the curve hourglass of a woman's figure.
But he's so, I think he's fine.
And then walking, there was no pausing in the walking.
The walking was on time?
他对着很多人眨眼。所以他知道他很酷。我们知道他很酷。哦，医生，不，他在跟着。他在眨眼，做着那种用手比划出女性身材曲线的动作。但他太，我觉得他很好。然后走路，走路没有停顿。走路很准时？
I was walking so much.
Walking was on time.
Couldn't stop walking.
Okay.
All night, all through the night.
It was basically they based, they based, uh, they based, uh, that,
horror movie this year
weapons on me because I would just walk out
我走得太多了。走路很准时。停不下来。好吧。整晚，整晚。基本上他们基于，他们基于，呃，他们基于，呃，今年的恐怖电影《武器》是因为我只会走出去
through the woods
right the arms out like you're flying
you know I remember
I remember when my my middle
son Abel was
you know he wasn't walking he was like 13 months
he was a little bit later and you know
his older brother had walked before a year
穿过树林，对，双臂张开，就像你在飞，你知道，我记得，我记得当我的二儿子阿贝尔，你知道，他不会走路，他当时13个月大，他晚了一点，你知道他哥哥在一岁前就走了，
so I know so we were nervous
not really but we're
and I remember my I remember Amy being like
when she's like he's not
walking he's not walking and I go
she goes he's never going to
look out on the street.
Do you see people dragging themselves by their hands,
所以我知道，所以我们很紧张，不是真的，但我们是，我记得我的，我记得艾米当时就像，当她就像他不会走路，他不会走路，我说，她说他永远不会走在街上。你看到人们用手拖着自己，
pulling themselves along the sidewalk?
He's going to get it.
He's going to pick it up, yeah.
And you'd ask people like, what are you doing?
Like, I never picked up walking.
It wasn't for me.
I never picked it up.
I never got it.
沿着人行道把自己拉过去吗？他会学会的。他会学会的，是的。你会问人们，你在做什么？就像，我从来没学会走路。那不适合我。我从来没学会。我从来没弄明白。
I mean, in New York, there might be like 20 to 40 of those people.
Well, that was just not for them.
Yeah, it's just not for them.
We'll be right back.
and now back to the show.
All right, so I want to talk about something
you're probably so sick of talking about
but I don't know anything about it,
我的意思是，在纽约，可能有20到40个那样的人。好吧，那只是不适合他们。是的，那只是不适合他们。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。好吧，所以我想谈谈你可能已经厌倦谈论的事情，但我对此一无所知，
which is the Staten Island Fair you bought with Pete Davidson
because I've seen you tell jokes about it
on the show on Saturday Night Live.
And I always laughed because I kind of know the gist of it,
but why and what was the plan
and what's the goal and all of that?
Because you paid, like,
you still have to pay like a dot, like don't you,
那就是你和皮特·戴维森买的斯塔滕岛渡轮，因为我在《周六夜现场》节目中看到你拿它开玩笑。我总是笑，因为我大概知道它的要点，但为什么，计划是什么，目标是什么，所有这些？因为你付了，就像，你还得付，就像，难道你不，
are you still paying for it?
These are like exact questions
of financial advisor asking me.
What is the plan?
And what is the...
Is it just fun?
But was it because of your...
Because these guys don't...
你还在为它付钱吗？这些就像财务顾问问我的确切问题。计划是什么？还有……这只是为了好玩吗？但这是因为你的……因为这些家伙不……
Jason and Willard...
No, but when I was doing my research about your reading,
is the journey you took an hour and a half
every single day to go to school from Staten Island to Manhattan
and you took the Staten Island ferry?
I took this...
I actually this one.
Oh, you did.
杰森和威拉德……不，但当我做关于你的阅读研究时，是你每天花一个半小时从斯塔滕岛去曼哈顿上学，你坐的是斯塔滕岛渡轮？我坐的是这个……我其实是这个。哦，你坐过。
Usually it was this one.
Which is, again, I explained to my friends and they're like,
yeah, but you also took the subway.
You didn't want to buy one of them.
or a bus.
It's named after J.F.K., it was commissioned for John F. Kennedy when he, after he died.
And it was, it was usually the 7 a.m. ferry that I took, got,
because I went up to this high school called Regis High School that's up on the Upper East Side,
通常是这个。这又是，我向我的朋友解释，他们说，是的，但你也坐了地铁。你不想买其中一个。或者公共汽车。它以J.F.K.命名，是在约翰·F·肯尼迪死后为他委托建造的。而且它，它通常是我坐的早上7点的渡轮，因为我去了上东区的一所叫里吉斯高中的高中，
and it's free if you get in. It's a really great school.
And so most people that go don't live in Manhattan.
Most people come from Brooklyn, Queen.
Staten Island, Jersey, even upstate.
And it was about an hour and a half every day?
Yeah, I took the bus.
There and back?
Come on.
如果你能进去，它是免费的。这是一所非常好的学校。所以大多数去那里的人不住在曼哈顿。大多数人来自布鲁克林、皇后区。斯塔滕岛、新泽西，甚至上州。每天大约一个半小时？是的，我坐公共汽车。来回？得了吧。
Each way.
Yeah, bus, ferry, subway.
How old were you?
6th.
14.
I did it 14 to 18.
Oh, my God.
It's just high school.
单程。是的，公共汽车、渡轮、地铁。你多大？六年级。14岁。我14到18岁时做了这件事。哦，天哪。这只是高中。
They don't have it.
But it was so, I mean, now it seems like a lot,
but now everything seems like less of a trip.
You know, it's like so, you know,
and I was never, you know, you,
and once you're there, you're like in Manhattan with your friends.
So it was very fun.
You'd use the time.
他们没有它。但这太，我的意思是，现在看起来很多，但现在一切看起来都不那么像旅行了。你知道，这太，你知道，一旦你到了那里，你就和你的朋友在曼哈顿了。所以这很有趣。你会利用时间
time for homework and whatnot?
Like you wouldn't really feel the, yeah?
Yeah, I never, I really never, rarely did homework at home because it was such a, you know,
trip.
Jason went to school on an actual bus.
The school was on a bus.
Which is true.
On a bus.
做作业之类的？就像你不会真的感觉到，是的？是的，我从来，我真的从来，很少在家里做作业，因为那是一个，你知道，旅行。杰森坐真正的公共汽车上学。学校在一辆公共汽车上。这是真的。在一辆公共汽车上。
Which is true.
On a bus.
Is that true?
Yeah, that is true.
How does that work?
Not well.
A lot of massaging.
That's also true.
这是真的。在一辆公共汽车上。那是真的吗？是的，那是真的。那是怎么运作的？不太好。很多按摩。那也是真的。
It's also true.
Ask him, please call and follow up.
What is the nature?
Why does massaging get involved?
No bus I'm ever on is like, and should we do a massage.
This is one of my favorite areas.
This is second only to Ernest Borgne
jerking up all over his house.
这也是真的。请问他，科林，跟进一下。性质是什么？为什么按摩会参与进来？没有我坐过的公共汽车是这样的，我们应该做个按摩。这是我最喜欢的领域之一。这仅次于欧内斯特·博格宁在他家到处自慰。
Keep going, Jason, go.
This was an experimental school, Colin.
A friend of my father's started one of these things
in his home out in Calabasas.
And it was called Heart Light, one word.
Heart Light, like L-I-G-H-T-L-H-T-L-L-E-H-T-L-L-T?
That's right.
And there were,
继续，杰森，继续。这是一所实验学校，科林。我父亲的一个朋友在卡拉巴萨斯的家里开了其中一所学校。它叫“心光”（Heart Light），一个词。心光，像L-I-G-H-T-L-H-T-L-L-E-H-T-L-L-T？那是对的。而且有，
Because Calabasasas, as you know, you're familiar with the city here.
It's a great deal of traffic, about another hour and a half, just like yours, from Calabasas into the city.
And so there were city days and country days.
The city days, we'd go in and see the museums.
Oh, my God.
And so they thought a good way to take advantage of that traffic time is to run classes in the back of this bus.
You know?
Because they were an incredibly progressive group.
因为卡拉巴萨斯，如你所知，你熟悉这里的城市。交通非常拥堵，大约又是另一个半小时，就像你的一样，从卡拉巴萨斯到城市。所以有城市日和乡村日。城市日，我们会进去看博物馆。哦，天哪。所以他们认为利用那段交通时间的最好方法是在这辆公共汽车后面上课。你知道吗？因为他们是一个非常进步的群体。
And so we did that.
There'd be some motion sickness.
And then on the country days, that's when we'd get into all the fun electives like massage.
It's true.
Building.
It wasn't an accredited school.
Yeah.
所以我们那样做了。会有一些晕车。然后在乡村日，那就是我们参加所有有趣的选修课的时候，比如按摩。这是真的。这是真的。建筑。那不是一所认证学校。是的。
Colin, I don't want to paint a...
I am fucking dying.
In an accurate picture here.
Yeah, yeah.
I've never seen Will laugh harder.
It's funny.
It was fun.
I love Jakey Bates so much.
科林，我不想描绘一个……我他妈的快笑死了。一个不准确的画面。是的，是的。我从没见过威利笑得这么厉害。很有趣。很有趣。我太爱杰基·贝茨了。
And I paid for.
Out of my own pocket, I was forced to pay for the school.
And not like regular bus fare, like school fare.
No.
Did you have to pay?
Do the massages extra?
And did you tip?
而且我付了钱。我自掏腰包，被迫支付学费。不是像普通的公交车费，而是学费。不。不。你必须付钱吗？按摩是额外的吗？你给小费了吗？
Did they pay you?
Yeah.
It depends if I'm giving or receiving on that.
On Tuesdays and Thursdays was the massaging.
So, Colin.
What a great, it sounds like such a great idea of concept.
Like, well, might as well, might as well, might as well,
Well, use the journey for the school.
他们付你钱吗？是的。这取决于我是给予还是接受。周二和周四是按摩时间。所以，科林。这听起来真是一个很棒的想法概念。就像，好吧，不妨，不妨，不妨，好吧，利用旅程来上学。
Sure.
By the way, that part makes kind of sense in that way, right?
Like that, yeah, it's a long way.
You'll have to applaud them for the idea.
Yeah.
And then you're sitting so long on the bus, you've got to provide massages.
It starts getting away from it pretty quick.
The donut they had to give each kid to sit on.
当然。顺便说一句，那部分在某种程度上是有道理的，对吧？就像那个，是的，路很长。你得为这个想法鼓掌。是的。然后你在公共汽车上坐了那么久，你必须提供按摩。它很快就开始偏离了。他们不得不给每个孩子一个甜甜圈来坐。
You know, there's so much class time on the bus.
It's not great.
Anyway, Carl, Lynn.
Well, so anyway, we bought it.
So I texted Pete, which is a, is a,
wrong person to text when you have
an idea like this and I was like, should we buy this?
Right, because he's going to say yes. The city was
你知道，公共汽车上有太多的上课时间。不太好。总之，卡尔，林。好吧，所以总之，我们买了它。所以我给皮特发了短信，这是一个，是一个，发短信给错人了，当你有一个这样的想法时，我说，我们应该买这个吗？对，因为他会说好。城市当时
auctioning it and he was, yeah, he was
immediately like, fuck yeah, we got to do this.
And I texted my dad who's a teacher
on Staten Island and he literally
was like, did you do your homework, which is such a teacher
thing to say. And I was like,
Dad, I'm just sort of texting you as a formality.
I already bought the boat. And then
正在拍卖它，他，是的，他立刻就像，去他妈的，我们必须这样做。我给我父亲发了短信，他是在斯塔滕岛的一名老师，他简直就像，你做作业了吗，这真是一个老师会说的话。我说，爸爸，我只是作为一种礼节给你发短信。我已经买了那艘船。然后
I texted Scarlett like
guess what, we own a ferry now
and she was like, we.
Did it stay in operation?
It was in operation until there was a new boat that came in.
And the new boat cost like $300 million to build.
So I was like, I'm getting an old one for only $280,000.
Right.
我给斯嘉丽发了短信，猜猜怎么着，我们现在拥有一艘渡轮了，她说，我们。它还在运营吗？它一直在运营，直到有一艘新船进来。新船造价大约3亿美元。所以我说，我只花了28万美元就买到了一艘旧的。对。
This is a deal.
That's all the ferry cost was $280,000?
Yeah, and I thought as a real, I was thinking in a real estate way,
if you put it somewhere, it's 70,000 square feet.
Oh, my gosh.
If you put that on a dock in Manhattan,
you've suddenly got basically a building on the waterfront.
And on that square footage to Scarlet.
这是一笔交易。渡轮的全部成本只有28万美元？是的，我当时想，作为一个房地产方式，如果你把它放在某个地方，它有7万平方英尺。哦，天哪。如果你把它放在曼哈顿的一个码头上，你突然就基本上在海滨有了一栋建筑。而且在斯嘉丽的那平方英尺上。
That could be a school.
That could be like three schools.
Kindergarten and elementary school and a high school.
Did you ever explore that opportunity?
Like you could actually park it there on the East River
and kind of have yourself a little,
a little, not a little, a house right there.
Yes, we are in the, we are in the,
那可以是一所学校。那可以是三所学校。幼儿园、小学和高中。你有没有探索过那个机会？就像你可以把它停在东河上，给自己一个小，一个小，不是一个小，就在那儿的房子。是的，我们正在，我们正在，
in the process of doing that.
And it's just, it's a long process because all the waterfront stuff is just, there's
environmental, there's, so we're in that process.
And I think we're actually getting close to that process having a dedicated spot.
Oh, wow.
Yes, which I joke about it a lot, but it is, and we've done some events on it where we really
have already made back the money we've invested and, and the money we've spent on stuff to dock it
and all that.
在这个过程中。这只是一个漫长的过程，因为所有的海滨东西都只是，有环境，有，所以我们在这个过程中。而且我觉得我们实际上已经接近那个过程有一个专门的地点了。哦，哇。是的，我经常拿它开玩笑，但它是，我们已经在上面做了一些活动，我们真的已经赚回了我们投资的钱，以及我们花在停靠它之类的东西上的钱。
So it's very missed reported that it is some.
sort of crazy money pit.
Hey man, I'm not your dad.
I'm not your dad.
You don't have to prove it.
It's going to be fine.
Wait, wait.
所以它被严重误报为一个疯狂的烧钱坑。嘿，伙计，我不是你爸爸。我不是你爸爸。你不需要证明它。它会没事的。它会没事的。等等，等等。
Is this a good financial sign where you're like, it's fine?
What's going to be, what's a home run?
What's the goal with it?
What's its partner?
I think the goal, a home run for me is like it's a thing that could be used for an event space,
but also has like a normal, like an everyday purpose of, like, two versions of it
to me are like it could be an operating entertainment like club like a place where you can go like you
could have parties or there's regular parties on it and then like I grew up growing up in Stadano and I went to
这是一个好的财务迹象吗，你就像，它很好？什么是本垒打？目标是什么？它的伙伴是什么？我觉得目标，对我来说一个本垒打就像它是一个可以用于活动空间的东西，但也像有一个正常的，就像一个日常目的，对我来说它的两个版本就像它可以是一个运营的娱乐场所，就像一个你可以去的地方，就像你可以举办派对，或者上面有定期的派对，然后就像我在斯塔滕岛长大，我去了
this place so that it was called the Great Hill swim club that was like a swim club where people would
just go and the kids could all hang out the adults could hang out and I could imagine creating a place like
that that's not like a weird fancy members club but it's actually more right like middle class in
Manhattan swim club.
You can go pay to use it.
Yeah, and you play it, and like there's a pool on the top and a diving board off the
top.
And you have these crazy views.
这个地方，它叫大山游泳俱乐部，那就像一个游泳俱乐部，人们会去那里，孩子们可以在那里玩，大人们可以在那里玩，我可以想象创造一个像那样的地方，不是像一个奇怪的昂贵的会员俱乐部，而是它实际上更对，就像曼哈顿的中产阶级游泳俱乐部。你可以付钱去使用它。是的，你付钱，就像上面有一个游泳池，上面有一个跳水板。而且你有这些疯狂的景色。
Sure, you can just dive into the East River and enjoy yourself.
You really enjoy yourself.
Really swept down the end of the sea.
Are you really pitching a swim club on the East River?
Yes, like, but a pool on the roof deck.
Diving board into the pool, not into the river.
It's like a cruise ship that doesn't leave.
A cruise ship that doesn't leave, but for families and it would be actually a great, like,
当然，你可以直接跳进东河，享受自己。你真的享受自己。真的被冲到了海的尽头。你真的在推销东河上的游泳俱乐部吗？是的，就像，但在屋顶甲板上有一个游泳池。跳水板跳进游泳池，而不是跳进河里。它就像一艘不离开的游轮。一艘不离开的游轮，但为了家庭，它实际上会是一个伟大的，就像，
people would spend summers there.
And then it's also movable.
So then half the year would be Miami,
and it would be, you'd have that in the winter
when it's cold here, and you'd have summer there,
and I think it could be a great thing.
And then you're moving to Miami.
Now I'm seeing that Carmella Seprano in you.
人们会在那里度过夏天。而且它也是可移动的。所以一年的一半时间会在迈阿密，当这里冷的时候，你会在冬天有那个，你会在那里有夏天，我觉得它可能是一个伟大的事情。然后你要搬到迈阿密。现在我看到了你身上那个卡梅拉·索普拉诺。
This is a picture.
Then we go to Miami, we take over the High Lie racket.
Oh, my God.
I got to say I'm kind of sold on this, Colin.
You kind of got me a little bit.
And then you'd have weddings and, like,
people already want to rent it out,
which we will do, we've done it a couple times,
这是一幅画。然后我们去迈阿密，我们接管回力球场。哦，天哪。我得说我有点被这个说服了，科林。你有点让我上钩了。然后你会举办婚礼，就像，人们已经想租用它了，我们会做的，我们已经做过几次了，
but we'll do it when we have a permanent spot,
it just makes the economics way better.
Yeah.
And this is all about economics ultimately.
Sure.
Obviously.
And then you registered in Liberia?
What's the...
但我们会等有了固定地点后再做，这样经济效益会好得多。是的。归根结底，这一切都是为了经济效益。当然。显而易见。那么你在利比里亚注册了？那是……
Yes, we're very open to pirates,
if anyone wants to know it.
I can't wait.
I'm going to approach it on a zodiac
with a mouthful of cat,
QAT.
Are we...
I feel like the cat usage is falling.
是的，我们对海盗非常开放，如果有人想知道的话。我迫不及待了。我要坐着橡皮艇，嘴里塞满卡特草（QAT）去接近他们。我们……我觉得卡特草的使用率在下降。
Have you been doing any recently?
I feel like we've not...
What is cat?
Well?
It's like a plant you chew that has like a crate, almost a combo of cocaine and hallucinogenic.
QAT?
Yeah.
你最近有在用吗？我觉得我们没有……什么是卡特草？什么是卡特草？嗯？它是一种你咀嚼的植物，几乎是可卡因和致幻剂的混合体。卡特草？是的。
The thing I read about it, that it makes you, it's the phrase I read was it makes you immune to atrocities, which is such a great description.
I think they use it a lot.
There was a lot of usage of it sort of in the horn of Africa, right?
Am I right about that?
And so, and a lot of, they accused a lot of these pirates of, who would go and commit
piracy of chewing on it and it makes
yeah it makes you just do crazy shit
it's an appetite suppressant as well
我读到过关于它的东西，它让你，我读到的短语是它让你对暴行免疫，这真是一个很棒的描述。我想他们经常使用它。在非洲之角有很多关于它的使用，对吧？我没说错吧？所以，很多人指责这些去从事海盗活动的海盗咀嚼它，它让你做出疯狂的事情，它也是一种食欲抑制剂。
it could give you it's like a you know
Jason you know this sounds like a fucking
silver bullet
where does one
do you need to be in the on the southern tip
of Africa to find it
no up in like up near sort of
Somalia Ethiopia up in there
它能给你，就像，你知道吗，杰森，这听起来像是一个该死的灵丹妙药，在哪里可以找到它？你需要去非洲南端才能找到它吗？不，在索马里、埃塞俄比亚附近，在那边。
eritria closer
yeah eritria yeah like right on the
it's very private company you see
these huge bushels of it.
It's terrific.
I got a guy.
I'll get you a number.
Are you on WhatsApp?
厄立特里亚更近，是的，厄立特里亚，就在那里，这是一家非常私人的公司，你会看到一大堆这种东西。太棒了。我有个熟人。我给你个号码。你有WhatsApp吗？
All right.
Colin, first question for our guest today.
Wait, Colin, let me take it.
So Colin, you go to this school.
You go to this grade school because you're really smart, clearly.
Well, no.
Well, say the school is Harvard.
No, I'm talking about the school.
好了。科林，我们今天嘉宾的第一个问题。等等，科林，让我来问。所以科林，你上了这所学校。你上这所小学是因为你真的很聪明，很明显。嗯，不。嗯，假设这所学校是哈佛。不，我说的是那所学校。
Oh, that one.
Oh, sorry.
For Regis.
Yeah, yeah.
From there, you get into Harvard,
evidently, based on your academic merit.
I'm guessing.
As opposed to...
哦，那一所。哦，抱歉。瑞吉斯（Regis）。是的，是的。从那里，你显然凭学术成绩进入了哈佛。我猜。而不是……
What do you mean?
I'm not a traditional athlete.
Yeah, like in your mind.
I'm not a D1 athlete in your money.
Well, you don't have your...
A name on a building is what I'm saying.
That's true.
Yeah.
你什么意思？我不是传统意义上的运动员。是的，就像你心里想的那样。在你的钱眼里，我不是一级运动员。嗯，你没有你的……我的意思是，建筑上没有你的名字。那是真的。是的。
Not even on my own ferry.
Right.
So at a heart...
Go ahead, Will.
No, no, I was going to say, you go take it over Harvard.
Oh, no, no, no.
I was just going to say, you know, you got involved with Lampoon, right?
Yeah.
甚至连我自己的渡轮上都没有。好吧。那么在哈佛……继续，威尔。不，不，我本来想说，你接管哈佛吧。哦，不，不，不。我只是想说，你知道，你参与了《讽刺家》（Lampoon），对吧？是的。
And then you wrote 80 pieces.
before you got one accepted.
What's the funny?
Yeah, trying out for it.
Tell me.
I mean, there was a time, Colin, five years ago,
where Sean was nominated for Best Interviewer.
是的。然后你写了80篇稿子才有一篇被录用。有什么好笑的？是的，试着加入它。告诉我。我的意思是，科林，五年前有段时间，肖恩被提名为最佳采访者。
On, in any podcast anywhere,
you think the fallout from a cat was deep.
The fallout for him and his questions has been.
And since that nomination, he's gotten tight,
and he can't spit it out.
No.
You can go.
No, you'll be quiet.
在任何地方的任何播客中，你认为卡特草的影响很深。他和他提出的问题所带来的影响也是如此。自那次提名以来，他变得紧张了，他无法表达出来。不。你可以继续。不，你会安静的。
No, because I wrote down a bunch of stuff that I actually want to know.
Give them your best one.
Take some time.
Find the best one in there and you give it to him.
Well, 80 sketches, none of them picked up, right?
I would stop it.
80 failures.
But I would stop it too.
不，因为我写下了一堆我真正想知道的事情。给他你最好的一个。花点时间。在里面找到最好的一个，然后给他。嗯，80个小品，一个都没被选中，对吧？我会停止的。80次失败。但我也会停止的。
How did you get involved in Lampoon?
Oh, that's so much better.
I didn't know about it.
Did you guys have any awareness?
Like, had you ever heard of it?
I mean, I had heard of the National Lampoon.
Yeah, I mean, but I didn't know what it meant.
I didn't understand what it was until I started knowing some of those S&L guys who'd come out of it, right?
你是怎么参与《讽刺家》的？哦，那好多了。我不知道。你们有任何了解吗？就像，你们听说过它吗？我的意思是，我听说过《国家讽刺家》。是的，我的意思是，但我不知道它意味着什么。直到我开始认识一些从中出来的《周六夜现场》（SNL）的人，我才明白它是什么，对吧？
So for Tracy, it is literally a magazine there at the school.
Yeah, it's just a magazine that has been there.
It's actually the 150th anniversary is coming up in like a week.
So we're going back.
back like Conan and a bunch of people
are all going to go back for this thing
but it just was like a student
magazine and then
所以对特雷西来说，它实际上是学校里的一本杂志。是的，它只是一本一直在那里的杂志。实际上，再过一周左右就是150周年纪念了。所以我们要回去。像柯南和一群人都要回去参加这个活动，但它就像一本学生杂志，然后
called like a precursor to like kind of like
something like the onion or even like mad magazine
right something like that yeah yeah and they started
people from there started like spy magazine back in the day
which I never remember that but that was
and they started they did like lampoon
magazines and yearbooks and stuff and then
spy magazine was I remember it in New York and the night
被称为像《洋葱报》甚至像《疯狂杂志》之类的先驱，对吧？类似那样的东西，是的，是的，他们开始，从那里出来的人在过去创办了《间谍杂志》，我从来不记得那个，但那是，他们开始，他们做了像《讽刺家》杂志和年鉴之类的东西，然后《间谍杂志》是我在纽约记得的，而且那个晚上
Spy magazine was phenomenal.
Yeah, I loved it.
It was so good.
And there were so many people, you mentioned Conan,
so many incredible comedy minds,
sort of big sort of icons of comedy,
you included have come out of the Lampoon.
A lot of people, a lot of, it was like back in the day,
《间谍杂志》太棒了。是的，我很喜欢它。它太好了。而且有很多人，你提到了柯南，很多不可思议的喜剧头脑，某种程度上是喜剧的偶像，包括你在内，都是从《讽刺家》出来的。很多人，很多，就像在过去，
it was a lot of writers, like literary writers, you know,
like John Updike and George Plympton and George Santayana
and all these, like, people.
And also business people, like William Randolph Hurst,
was a member. There's a business board. So he, a lot of, he helped fund the building that's there,
like this Lampoon Castle. And he and Isabel are Stuart Gardner, who has the museum, who had the
museum in Boston, she collected a lot of stuff that went to that museum on the same trip with him.
And he, a lot of the stuff he got went to the Lampoon, which is pretty cool. And it's a bit of a feeder
有很多作家，比如文学作家，你知道，像约翰·厄普代克、乔治·普林普顿、乔治·桑塔亚纳和所有这些人。还有商人，比如威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特，他也是成员。有一个商业委员会。所以他，很多，他帮助资助了那里的建筑，就像这个《讽刺家》城堡。他和伊莎贝尔·斯图尔特·加德纳，那个有博物馆的人，在波士顿有博物馆的人，在同一次旅行中和他一起收集了很多去那个博物馆的东西。而且他，他得到的东西很多都去了《讽刺家》，这很酷。而且它有点像是一个输送带
for S&L, too, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So like around the 70s, a lot of it was this guy,
Jim Downey, who I'm sure you guys have met through these, but he,
He went to SNL.
He was a writer the first year at SNL of SNL.
And then after that, people kind of saw that you could write in comedy instead of necessarily only writing novels.
And then people started getting into it there.
But I didn't know, so I didn't know, have any awareness of it when I went, like, I went to school for economics, weirdly, and I didn't have any idea that there was, like a humor magazine or anything like that.
And I had always done comedy things.
也是为《周六夜现场》输送人才的，不是吗？是的。是的。是的。所以大约在70年代，很多都是这个叫吉姆·唐尼的人，我相信你们通过这些已经见过他了，但他，他去了《周六夜现场》。他是《周六夜现场》第一年的编剧。在那之后，人们开始意识到你可以在喜剧中写作，而不一定只是写小说。然后人们开始进入那里。但我不知道，所以我去的时候没有任何意识，就像，我奇怪地去学了经济学，我根本不知道那里有什么幽默杂志之类的东西。而且我一直都在做喜剧相关的事情。
you didn't know it was really a job.
You just did it with your friends.
It wasn't a destination for you to get into comedy necessarily.
Yeah, I didn't know you could really.
Like it didn't seem like a real thing.
And so that was the first place where I went
and people just were really funny
and I wanted to hang out there.
你不知道那真的是一份工作。你只是和朋友们一起做。它不一定是你进入喜剧的目的地。是的，我不知道你真的可以。它看起来不像是一件真实的事情。所以那是我去的第一地方，人们真的很有趣，我想和他们待在一起。
And then I started learning that people would graduate
and go apply and work at different shows.
And so did you just apply for SNL?
How did that happen?
Yeah, you just cold submitted.
That's a packet.
I actually submitted a packet.
Yeah.
然后我开始了解到人们毕业后会去申请并在不同的节目中工作。所以你只是申请了《周六夜现场》？那是怎么发生的？是的，你只是冷不丁地提交了。那是一个作品集。我实际上提交了一个作品集。是的。
And then it was just the wrong.
time of year. I submitted it and so no one read it. No, no agent, no nothing. You just did it
yourself. No. No. No agent, nothing. And, and, uh, I submitted it and no one looked at it because
it was the wrong time of year. And then the next time, you know, it was like the next, uh, summer.
And then I ran into someone who was, uh, who had been in the lampoon, who was like,
I heard it's, you have to submit in the summer in like June or July, whatever the deadline was.
And so I put together another packet and submitted it then.
And I was, you know, I was just lucky there was a ton of turnover.
然后只是时间不对。我提交了它，所以没人读。不，没有经纪人，什么都没有。你只是自己做的。不。不。没有经纪人，什么都没有。而且，呃，我提交了它，没人看，因为时间不对。然后下一次，你知道，那是下一个，呃，夏天。然后我遇到了一个人，呃，他曾在《讽刺家》待过，他说，我听说，你必须在夏天，在六月或七月，无论截止日期是什么时候提交。所以我整理了另一个作品集并在那时提交了。而且我，你知道，我很幸运，当时人员流动很大。
I wrote like six sketches.
And there was a bunch of writers that left.
And then I got, like Tina was one of the headwriters, Harper Steel.
And they liked some, you know, something that was in there and brought me in an interview.
And then I interviewed with Lorne, which was insane.
And then just was very lucky that there was an extra spot.
And I was probably the last person hired.
and I got hired with Samberg and Samburg and Sadecas and Bill Hader and Kristen Wig
我写了大约六个小品。有一群编剧离开了。然后我得到了，像蒂娜是首席编剧之一，哈珀·斯蒂尔。他们喜欢里面的一些东西，把我叫去面试。然后我和洛恩面试，这太疯狂了。然后非常幸运有一个额外的名额。我可能是最后一个被录用的人。我和萨姆伯格、萨德基斯、比尔·哈德和克里斯汀·韦格一起被录用。
and then the Lonely Island guys, Yorma and Akeva and a guy Brian Tucker who came from...
Yeah, Tucker, and Sadegis was just hired as a writer first for that first year.
Yeah, yeah, that was, he just started, he had just got hired into the cast when I started.
So that was the eight of us that all started.
That's amazing.
And how old were you when you started?
22.
That's amazing.
还有孤独岛的那帮人，约尔马和阿基瓦，还有一个叫布莱恩·塔克的家伙，他来自……是的，塔克，萨德基斯第一年只是被雇为编剧。是的，是的，那是，他刚开始，我开始的时候他刚被雇进演员阵容。所以那是我们八个一起开始的。这太神奇了。你开始的时候多大？22岁。这太神奇了。
So, well, so you go into school to study economics.
Was there ever a thought that there would be a career in economics?
Or was it just, I got to declare a major and let's have it be this?
I think it was a, I thought I could maybe work.
I mean, I interned at like Merrill Lynch when I was in high school.
Wow.
I just thought that was, in Staten Island, like there were certain jobs.
All my family was firefighters, like my whole mom, like my mom was in the fire department, my grandpa, my great grandpa.
所以，嗯，你去学校学经济学。有没有想过会有经济学方面的职业？还是只是，我得申报一个专业，就选这个吧？我想这是一个，我以为我可能可以工作。我的意思是，我在高中时曾在美林证券实习。哇。我只是认为那是，在斯塔滕岛，就像有一些特定的工作。我所有的家人都是消防员，就像我整个妈妈，我妈妈在消防局，我爷爷，我曾祖父。
So that was like a clear path I knew.
And then from Staten Island,
like people would go take the ferry to Wall Street.
There were people that worked in finance.
And then obviously I knew about being a doctor
or being a lawyer.
Like those were the kind of jobs that I understood.
And so I sort of thought I would do something in that range.
所以那是一条我知道的清晰道路。然后从斯塔滕岛，人们会坐渡轮去华尔街。有些人从事金融工作。然后显然我知道当医生或律师。那些是我理解的工作类型。所以我有点认为我会做那个范围内的事情。
Like I would do work in finance
or I would try to be a doctor someday
or try to be a lawyer.
And then so then you start to get kind of this
being your bonnet for comedy.
Did you like talk to?
to me about the calculation you were making
at, so you're sitting at
比如我会从事金融工作，或者我有一天会尝试成为一名医生或律师。然后你开始对喜剧产生兴趣。你能不能跟我谈谈你当时做的计算，所以你坐在
Harvard where you really, whatever
field you decide to study
and get your diploma in,
get your
degree in,
you've got a pretty good
sort of base salary to
assume there. And so like picking
哈佛，无论你决定学习什么领域并获得文凭，获得学位，你都有一个相当不错的底薪可以假设。所以选择
what you're going to get your degree
in is kind of, you're
declaring what your life is going to be,
and it's going to be pretty good.
And so you're thinking,
comedy, economics, or I can study this,
at what point were you kind of like all in?
It's going to be, I'm going to go into comedy writing,
你要获得什么学位有点像是在宣布你的人生将会是什么样，而且会相当不错。所以你在想，喜剧，经济学，或者我可以学习这个，在什么时刻你有点像是全心投入了？它将会是，我要进入喜剧写作，
or did you mitigate that risk by minoring in something else?
Like, just walk me through that.
I, you know, my parents definitely were worried, you know,
just once I was going down a comedy path.
I mean, when I was there, I switched,
so I switched from economics to when I declare,
I declare I was going to be in economics,
but then when you actually had to declare,
或者你通过辅修其他专业来降低风险？就像，带我了解一下。我，你知道，我的父母肯定很担心，你知道，一旦我走上喜剧道路。我的意思是，我在那里的时候，我换了，所以我从经济学换到了，当我申报时，我申报我要学经济学，但当你真正需要申报时，
I studied Russian literature.
Like I went, that's lucrative.
I was reading a bunch of books in Russia,
and so I was like, and then at some point I had to learn Russian,
I had to live in St. Petersburg for a summer,
and I was going down that path.
But not, I didn't.
Let's pause there for one second.
我学习了俄罗斯文学。就像我去，那很赚钱。我在读一堆俄罗斯的书，所以我当时想，然后在某个时候我不得不学习俄语，我不得不在圣彼得堡住了一个夏天，我正走在那条路上。但没有，我没有。让我们在那里暂停一下。
Yeah.
Why Russian literature?
What was super interesting?
Are you a Russian asset?
I wish.
I'm open to it.
Are they asking?
I just,
是的。为什么是俄罗斯文学？什么超级有趣？你是俄罗斯的资产吗？我希望是。我对此持开放态度。他们在问吗？我只是，
I just liked the books. I just liked reading, I read in high school, I read some Nabokov and Tolstoy and Dostoevsky books and senior year. I liked them, so I wanted to read more. And then it just kept going down that line. Like, I didn't have a plan for it. I certainly wasn't assuming it was going to be a career.
Right. Can you speak Russian? I was, yeah, fluent in Russian.
Wow. That's crazy. Wow, that's awesome. Okay. All right. So then, so then I, sorry, then I, I, I, I, I, I, really,
I realized, I guess, when I was at the Lampoon
that most of the things I did in my life leading up to that
were kind of comedy versions of what I did.
Like I ran the school newspaper, but I did the comedy,
you know, wrote comedy for it rather than like regular news.
我只是喜欢这些书。我只是喜欢阅读，我在高中时读了一些纳博科夫、托尔斯泰和陀思妥耶夫斯基的书，在最后一年。我喜欢它们，所以我想读更多。然后它就一直沿着那条线走下去。就像，我没有计划。我当然没有假设它会成为一种职业。对。你会说俄语吗？我，是的，俄语流利。哇。那太疯狂了。哇，那太棒了。好的。好的。所以然后，所以然后我，抱歉，然后我，我，我，我，我，我，我真的，我意识到，我想当我在《讽刺家》时，我一生中做的大部分事情都是我所做事情的喜剧版本。比如我经营校报，但我做的是喜剧，你知道，为它写喜剧而不是像普通新闻那样。
I was working at a newspaper, but I mostly wanted to write comedy there.
I performed in plays and musicals, but I really only cared about the comedy part of it,
not the serious part of it.
I did speech and debate, but I only did.
funny like oratories that I wrote that were kind of versions of comedy or performed funny things
and didn't do any, you know.
So I just, I started realizing that that was probably where my interest was even if I was doing
any of these other ways and that there's not really a funny version of finance.
我在报社工作，但我大部分时间想在那里写喜剧。我在戏剧和音乐剧中表演，但我真正关心的只是喜剧部分，而不是严肃的部分。我参加了演讲和辩论，但我只做。有趣的演讲，我写的，是某种喜剧版本，或者表演有趣的事情，没有做任何，你知道。所以我只是，我开始意识到那可能就是我的兴趣所在，即使我正在以任何其他方式做这些事情，而且金融并没有真正有趣的版本。
Right.
Again, along with the statements, it's not, yeah.
Unless you buy a Staten Island fair.
Yes, then it is.
There's certainly some more predictable financial security in the,
lane of economics as opposed to
the world of comedy.
You're talking about it. You're talking about it like taking
对。同样，随着声明，它不是，是的。除非你买一艘斯塔滕岛渡轮。是的，那它就是。在经济学领域，相对于喜剧世界，肯定有更可预测的经济保障。你在谈论它。你谈论它就像下注
making the bet on it and going all in.
Yeah. Yeah, I did. I just did. I didn't have another plan
and I didn't, I honestly don't know that I could have imagined
then going to law school or after that.
I think I just decided that whatever version of it
it was going to end up being, I was going to enjoy
being around people that were funny and doing things that I'd
tried things that were funny and regardless of it's lifestyle didn't necessarily matter it's so great i mean i'm
并全押一样。是的。是的，我做了。我只是做了。我没有其他计划，而且我，老实说，我不知道我当时能否想象去法学院或在那之后。我想我只是决定，无论它最终会成为什么版本，我都会喜欢和有趣的人在一起，做我尝试过的有趣的事情，无论它的生活方式是否重要，这太棒了，我的意思是，我
sorry a reason i keep hammering on this because you know i've got a daughter that's in her first year of
college and and and even my youngest the 14 year old she's you know they're both sort of like you know
as kids do wondering about you know am i doing the things that i should be doing to set myself up for
the best possible you know life am i making the right decisions um and i keep saying well as long as
you're pointed at something, a lot of opportunity comes your way. And so you're going to see some
forks in the road that might not necessarily be, you know, the lane you're on right now. And that's,
that's good. That's okay. But you're not going to find those forks unless you're driven in,
in some direction on something. It doesn't matter what that is. And so I guess you're sort of a great
抱歉，我一直强调这一点，因为你知道我有一个女儿正在上大学一年级，甚至我最小的14岁的孩子，她，你知道，他们都像孩子们一样，想知道（你知道）我是否在做我应该做的事情，为自己创造最好的生活，我是否在做正确的决定，嗯，我一直说，只要你指向某件事，很多机会就会随之而来。所以你会看到一些岔路口，可能不一定是你现在走的这条路。那很好。那没关系。但除非你在某件事上朝着某个方向努力，否则你不会找到那些岔路口。无论那是什么都不重要。所以我猜你是一个很好的
example of that. You're driving towards economics and you found comedy. Yeah. And for her, too,
like, I mean, I think the peer element of it is so important to me. You know, you find, you find,
people that are serious about something, even if it's comedy, and are really driven or
really, you know, and then you learn from them, you're competitive in a healthy way with them,
you're, you know, you're hearing about opportunities from them eventually, you know,
like when you're trying to do things, or I think that's so important too.
And so that you have a, you're not doing it in a vacuum.
Right.
例子。你朝着经济学方向努力，然后你发现了喜剧。是的。而且对她来说，也是，我的意思是，我认为同伴因素对我来说非常重要。你知道，你找到，你找到，对某件事认真的人，即使是喜剧，并且非常有动力，或者真的，你知道，然后你向他们学习，你以一种健康的方式与他们竞争，你，你知道，你最终会从他们那里听到机会，你知道，就像当你试图做事情时，或者我认为这也很重要。所以你有一个，你不是在真空中做这件事。对。
We'll be right back.
All right.
Back to the show.
So you go to Estinnell that year that you mentioned with all those dudes.
How long was it before you got the update chair?
Yeah, did you go with the intention of wanting to do update?
Or did you go?
Or did it just happen?
我们马上回来。好了。回到节目。所以你像你提到的那样在那一年去了《周六夜现场》。在你得到更新（Update）主持席位之前过了多久？是的，你去的时候有想做更新的意图吗？还是你去了？还是它只是发生了？
No, no, no.
I wouldn't even, I wouldn't have conceived of that.
I think I...
You know, Colin, I called you in here because I think you're ready.
What?
Was it kind of like that?
He did call him.
Yes, he came.
不，不，不。我甚至不会想到这一点。我想我……你知道，科林，我把你叫到这里是因为我认为你准备好了。什么？是那样的吗？他确实叫他了。是的，他来了。
I didn't even know why he was calling.
me in and he's like
so you think you could do update
like asking me
yeah and I was like
meanwhile you'd only been a writer
on the show for a year or two or three
no no I'd been there for a long so I mean I'd been there
我甚至不知道他为什么要叫我进去，他说，你觉得你能做更新吗？就像问我一样。是的，我当时想，与此同时，你只在节目中当了几年或两三年的编剧。不，不，我在那里待了很长，所以我，我的意思是，我在那里
for a long time I was there
I was probably there
eight years or something seven or eight years
that's what I was getting it yeah and because I
not on camera so I got as and all I would
I would have been happy to
have any job in comedy right like I
applied everywhere that had a job
待了很长时间，我在那里，我可能在那里待了八年左右，七或八年，这就是我得到它的原因，是的，因为我不在镜头前，所以我得到了《周六夜现场》，我会，我会很高兴在喜剧中做任何工作，对吧？就像我申请了所有有工作的地方。
I wrote a I
I wrote a arrested development spec script
when I was going out.
I feel like you told me this once.
Maybe I did. Maybe I did tell you.
Yeah.
And it sounds familiar.
Oh my God, I want to read that.
我写了一个，我写了一个《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）的剧本，当我出去的时候。我觉得你曾经告诉过我这个。也许我告诉过你。也许我告诉过你。是的。听起来很熟悉。天哪，我想读那个。
What was Job's story?
Sorry, sorry.
It doesn't matter.
It was Joe Bay Story or B story.
I'm not sure he was in it.
Yeah, Joe, I want to have a real Joe that episode.
So even though you had done?
乔的故事是什么？抱歉，抱歉。没关系。那是乔的B故事。没关系。我不确定他在里面。是的，乔，我想在那一集中有一个真正的乔。所以即使你已经做了？
Maybe the one, can I tell you the one thing I remember about it,
which is that now, which is that it was for
for George Michael was
self-conscious and wanted to lose weight.
And so he tried joining a,
what he saw was a recreation society,
but it was a recreation society.
And he got cast as Ben Franklin,
也许那个，我能告诉你我记得的一件事吗，就是现在，就是它是关于乔治·迈克尔很自卑，想减肥。所以他尝试加入一个，他看到的娱乐协会，但那是一个娱乐协会。他被选为本·富兰克林，
and so ended up gaining a bunch of weight.
That's really funny.
That's a great bit.
So dumb.
Oh, my God, Mitch Hurwitz would have loved that.
That's a great bit.
So I wrote applied all these places,
and I was very, you know, very lucky to get hired
所以最终增加了很多体重。那真的很有趣。那是一个很棒的梗。太蠢了。天哪，米奇·赫维茨会喜欢那个的。那是一个很棒的梗。所以我写了申请所有这些地方，而且我非常，你知道，非常幸运被录用
SNL and I felt like then I just wanted to be good at that and figure it out and enjoy it.
I loved, I loved it.
No, on-camera aspirations.
No, not, I mean, but I did, I had performing aspirations.
I just didn't think of it always as SNL-related.
Like I did stand-up.
Right.
So while that time, I'm doing stand-up in New York.
《周六夜现场》，我觉得那时我只想在那方面做得好，弄清楚它并享受它。我爱，我爱它。不，没有镜头前的抱负。不，不是，我的意思是，但我确实，我有表演的抱负。我只是不总是认为它与《周六夜现场》有关。就像我做单口喜剧。对。所以在那段时间，我在纽约做单口喜剧。
Oh, you are?
Okay.
Yeah, while I'm writing, I would go after, when there's nights that you can get out and I would go do
stand-up, like three or four times.
or whatever.
Did you, did you ever, were there ever any summer, like, end of seasons of S&L,
and you can be as honest as you want to be, where you were like, you know what, I'm going to move,
I'm going to leave, I want to do something else.
哦，你是吗？好的。是的，当我在写作时，我会去，当有晚上你可以出去时，我会去表演单口喜剧，就像三次或四次。或者无论什么。你，你曾经，有没有过夏天，比如《周六夜现场》的季末，你可以尽可能诚实，你当时想，你知道吗，我要搬走，我要离开，我想做点别的。
Like, did you ever have one of those moments in those eight years before you got the update chair?
Yes.
Not, like, not, because there was sort of a little bit of a, like, you know, I had a journey
as a writer there where I got promoted to, like, a writing supervisor, and then I got promoted
to be head writer.
and that was like a real honor that I loved the idea of getting to do that someday.
So that was really important to me, and I felt excited about that.
It was, I found it to be a really nightmarish job in a lot of ways
就像，在你得到更新主持席位之前的八年里，你有没有过那样的时刻？是的。不是，就像，不是，因为我在那里有一段旅程，作为一名编剧，我被提升为，比如写作主管，然后我被提升为首席编剧。那是一个我非常喜欢的真正的荣誉，有一天能做那个。所以这对我很重要，我对此感到兴奋。它，我发现它在很多方面是一份非常噩梦般的工作，
because you're suddenly doing the same job you're doing,
but you're also having to manage everyone you're working with.
And that was a very weird period of time for me
because it also coincided with getting update,
like it almost exactly coincided.
No, oh, really?
Yeah, it was like maybe a year or half a year that I was a head writer
and then got update.
因为你突然在做你正在做的工作，但你也不得不管理你一起工作的每个人。那对我来说是一个非常奇怪的时期，因为它也恰逢得到更新，就像它几乎完全重合。不，哦，真的吗？是的，就像我当首席编剧大约一年或半年，然后得到了更新。
But I had my only, as I was there for a little longer,
I did like performing, I did like doing stand-up.
And honestly, I wanted to do some version of acting,
not necessarily acting like in a serious way,
but performing in some way in a comedy way.
Yeah. And I thought I've done this as a writer now.
I thought maybe after a few years,
of being head writer, maybe there would just be something else I'd want to do
但我有我唯一的，当我在那里待得更久一点时，我确实喜欢表演，我确实喜欢做单口喜剧。老实说，我想做某种形式的表演，不一定是严肃的表演，而是以某种方式表演，以喜剧的方式。是的。我想我已经作为一名编剧做到了这一点。我想也许几年后，作为首席编剧，也许会有其他我想做的事情，
or create a show as a writer or do something different.
And then got this opportunity to do update.
And then it kind of went so badly at first for a while
that I then thought I was going to lose both jobs,
that I was going to be so bad at update that I was also not going to be a writer.
Why did it go bad?
What do you mean?
It just was, I mean, I think Seth was leaving.
或者作为编剧创作一个节目，或者做一些不同的事情。然后得到了这个机会做更新。然后它起初有一段时间进行得非常糟糕，以至于我当时认为我会失去两份工作，我会做更新做得那么糟糕，以至于我也不会成为一名编剧。为什么它进行得不好？你什么意思？它只是，我的意思是，我想塞斯要离开了。
Seth was leaving.
He was, you know, very loved doing the job.
You know, I came in, I started with Cecily Strong.
We did like six episodes together.
That's it at the end of the year.
Yeah.
And, you know, I think I just wasn't very good at it.
It's a hard thing to come in and do.
塞斯要离开了。他，你知道，非常喜欢做这份工作。你知道，我进来了，我和塞西莉·斯特朗一起开始。我们一起做了大约六集。在年底就这些了。是的。而且，你知道，我想我只是不擅长它。进来做这件事是一件很难的事情。
And I don't, I think I was like really nervous.
And I probably that, I probably smiled or laughed in a way that made people think I was kind of cocky about it.
When I actually felt very much at sea and panicking.
People were giving me all kinds of advice that was kind of.
contradictory and I didn't know how to do it.
And then basically in the summer, I got told, after those six episodes, I got told, like,
you might get to audition for it.
And I was like, which seems like a bad job, it's signed to audition for the job you currently have.
而且我不知道，我想我当时真的很紧张。而且我可能，我可能以一种让人们认为我对此有点自大的方式微笑或大笑。当我实际上感到非常迷茫和恐慌时。人们给了我各种各样的建议，这些建议有点。矛盾，我不知道该怎么做。然后基本上在夏天，我被告知，在那六集之后，我被告知，就像，你可能会去试镜它。我当时想，这看起来是一份糟糕的工作，去为你目前的工作试镜。
And then they tried me with different combinations of people also.
So, like, I did an audition with Leslie Jones.
I did an audition with Vanessa Bear.
I did an audition with Chris Kelly, who's a really funny writer at our show.
and I did and I auditioned with Che,
who I knew from stand-up
from before he came to Asin-L as a writer,
and I loved the idea of getting to do with him
然后他们也尝试了我和不同的人的组合。所以，就像，我和莱斯利·琼斯一起试镜。我和凡妮莎·贝尔一起试镜。我和克里斯·凯利一起试镜，他是在我们节目中一个非常有趣的编剧。而且我，我和切一起试镜，我在他来到《周六夜现场》当编剧之前就从单口喜剧中认识他，我喜欢和他一起做这件事的想法，
because he's really funny,
but I had no idea what they were going to go with.
And they also brought in Anthony Jesselnick
just to audition on his own,
just to go in a totally different direction,
bring someone else in.
And I'm sure he would have been very funny at it.
And then they did these audits,
因为他真的很有趣，但我不知道他们会选择什么。而且他们还带了安东尼·杰塞尔尼克只是为了他自己试镜，只是为了走一个完全不同的方向，带进另一个人。而且我相信他会做得非常有趣。然后他们做了这些试镜，
auditions and then I didn't even know what was happening.
And suddenly, so I was involved in all these processes of cast and hiring.
And then suddenly I was completely cut off really from like all my friends for, for periods of time
where everyone was probably nervous for me or didn't know whether I should do the job genuinely.
Like not that they were being bad friends.
Just probably were like, I don't know if he's right for it.
And then they picked me and Che.
And then for like the first two years at least, we think,
试镜，然后我甚至不知道发生了什么。突然间，所以我参与了所有这些演员和招聘的过程。然后突然间我完全与我所有的朋友隔绝了，真的，有一段时间，每个人可能都在为我紧张，或者不知道我是否应该真正做这份工作。就像不是他们是坏朋友。只是可能都在想，我不知道他是否适合它。然后他们选了我和切。然后至少前两年，我们认为，
thought we were going to get fired every summer.
Like we were put on suspension, kind of, or put on extension, and we didn't know whether
we were going to get it or not, and we, and then something sort of just started clicking,
really just we gave, Lauren was, we were lucky that he gave us enough time to start figuring
it out, and then, and then it started feeling okay, and then it started feeling better and not
like a huge existential crisis.
It's so fun to watch you guys, yeah, you guys have such a great dynamic.
You're so good at it.
我们认为我们每年夏天都会被解雇。就像我们被停职了，某种程度上，或者被延长了，我们不知道我们是否会得到它，我们，然后事情某种程度上就开始点击了，真的只是我们给了，洛恩是，我们很幸运，他给了我们足够的时间开始弄清楚它，然后，然后它开始感觉还可以，然后它开始感觉更好，而不是像一场巨大的生存危机。看你们表演太有趣了，是的，你们有这么好的化学反应。你们太擅长了。
One of the funniest things I'd ever seen was,
and I couldn't believe I was watching it,
and I can't believe it happened,
which is Michael told the audience before you showed up
to not laugh at one joke you said.
And that was the joke.
And I'm watching it going, oh, my God,
this is horrible to what?
我见过最有趣的事情之一是，我不敢相信我正在看它，而且我不敢相信它发生了，那就是迈克尔在你出现之前告诉观众不要笑你说的任何一个笑话。而那正是那个笑话。我看着它说，天哪，这太可怕了，什么？
Like, did you, what was going through your head?
Oh, I was like, it's all over.
It's all truly.
Because it was so perfect
It was so perfect
Because I changed a joke between dress and air early on
And so he had told
He met, by the way, this is the most proactive
就像，你，你脑子里在想什么？哦，我当时想，一切都结束了。一切都真的。因为它太完美了，因为它太完美了，因为我在彩排和直播之间很早就改了一个笑话。所以他告诉，顺便说一句，这是最主动的
Che has ever been about anything
He went and met with the audience
Before they loaded in
Like looked them in the eyes
And we're like, listen, you're not laughing
I don't care, you do not laugh at anything
Colin says
This is while they're still downstairs?
切曾经做过的任何事情，他去见了观众，在他们入场之前，就像看着他们的眼睛，说，听着，你们不笑，我不在乎，你们不要笑科林说的任何事情。这是在他们还在楼下的时候吗？
This is while I'm waiting
Yeah, they're still waiting downstairs
to get loaded in, and he goes down, meets them, tells them this.
I remember watching it, I couldn't believe it.
And then, so I changed one joke early on between dress and air,
and so at air, it bombs.
And in my head, I'm like, oh, I shouldn't have taken that swing.
But it's perfect because I don't, I could still believe it's, you know.
这是在我等待的时候，是的，他们还在楼下等着入场，他下去，见他们，告诉他们这个。我记得看着它，我不敢相信。然后，所以我很早就改了一个笑话，在彩排和直播之间，所以在直播时，它炸了。在我的脑海里，我当时想，哦，我不应该冒那个险。但它很完美，因为我不，我仍然可以相信它是，你知道。
Then he goes and he crushes.
He kills.
She does two jokes, crushes.
Then it comes back to me, and I,
tell the next one, which worked really well
at dress, and it bombs. And I'm like,
oh, my God.
At first I was like, oh, maybe it's a bad crowd.
然后他去，他压倒性地成功了。他杀死了。他做了两个笑话，压倒性地成功。然后它回到我这里，我，讲下一个，在彩排时效果很好，它炸了。我当时想，天哪。起初我当时想，哦，也许这是一个糟糕的观众。
Then he crushes. So I'm like, oh, no.
Meanwhile, he keeps looking at you like,
oh, boy. Yeah, just not leading.
And then the fourth joke
bombs, and I'm
truly thinking, like, my career's
over. Like, it's a turn, I'm never getting it back,
it's over. And someone
然后他压倒性地成功。所以我当时想，哦，不。与此同时，他一直看着你，就像，哦，孩子。是的，只是没有引导。然后第四个笑话炸了，我真的在想，就像，我的职业生涯结束了。就像，这是一个转折，我永远无法挽回它，它结束了。然后有人
in that he had a plant in the audience
that he had yell out,
you stink after.
So simple.
So dumb.
John Higgins
and he just goes,
在那个，他在观众中安插了一个人，他让他大喊，你很臭。太简单了。太简单了。太蠢了。约翰·希金斯，他只是说，
you stink!
Like old-timey heckling.
Not you suck.
You're a bum!
And I heard that and I was like
in full, you can tell if you look at it,
in shock.
And then Shay's like,
你很臭！就像老式的起哄。不是你烂透了。你是个流浪汉！我听到了那个，我当时就像完全，如果你看它，你可以看出来，处于震惊中。然后切说，
dude, I got to tell you.
I told them not to laugh at anything.
And I was like, you motherfucker.
Yeah, it's so angry.
So,
Such a good thing.
So angry.
Is this live?
伙计，我得告诉你。我告诉他们不要笑任何事情。我当时想，你这个混蛋。是的，太生气了。所以，这么好的事情。太生气了。这是直播吗？
Is this on an episode?
Yes, live.
What a great bit.
You can YouTube it.
It is so horrifying.
Now you know, and you'll look at it, you know, and it's.
Your face is.
I was genuinely traumatized for like two more shows.
这是在某一集吗？是的，直播。多棒的梗。你可以在YouTube上搜到它。它太可怕了。现在你知道了，你会看着它，你知道，它是。你的脸是。我真的被创伤了，又做了两场节目。
Because then the next show back.
I didn't know what to, I didn't know what was coming.
Did you immediately start thinking about payback?
Are you a, are you a prankster?
Of course.
By the way, did Chey run it by Lauren?
No, he just did it.
He went rogue.
因为然后下一场节目回来。我不知道该，我不知道会发生什么。你有没有立即开始考虑报复？你是一个恶作剧者吗？当然。顺便说一句，切有没有把这件事告诉洛恩？不，他只是做了。他单干了。
He did.
and I think basically Lorne
talked him into
eventually telling me
versus never telling me.
Right, right, right, right.
And which was, which made it much better,
actually, that he did tell me
他做了。而且我认为基本上洛恩最终说服他告诉我，而不是永远不告诉我。对，对，对，对。这，这让它好多了，实际上，他确实告诉了我
and otherwise would have been perhaps...
No, it's better to get your reaction on camera
and see it dawn on you.
I mean, that's, but it's amazing.
And then, and now what I love Colin
is you're appearing more and more as Pete Hig Seth,
which is so brilliant.
It's so good.
否则可能……不，最好在镜头前得到你的反应，看着它在你身上显现。我的意思是，那是，但这太神奇了。然后，现在我喜欢科林的是你越来越多地以皮特·赫格塞斯（Pete Hegseth）的身份出现，这太精彩了。这太好了。
It's such a gift.
But does any part of you
get nervous about, you know, doing that at all?
Well, on a couple levels.
I mean, first of all, I still, I get nervous even within an S&L world because it's suddenly a new
thing and a new rhythm.
Like, even though I've been there for so long, coming out in the cold open is its own weird
feeling.
这真是一份礼物。但你有没有任何一部分对，你知道，做这件事感到紧张？嗯，在几个层面上。我的意思是，首先，我仍然，我即使在《周六夜现场》的世界里也会感到紧张，因为它突然是一件新事物和一个新的节奏。就像，即使我在那里待了这么久，在冷开场中出来也是一种奇怪的感觉。
And after all these years, it's nerve-wracking.
You've got to private, you don't have to admit to this, but you've got to privately
just be like so excited to go out there and show off.
a little bit because you're so goddamn good at what you do.
Whether you're doing the update or doing Hegset,
I mean, it's just, you gotta be,
I'd love to see more doing your thing.
I think it's one of my,
而且这么多年后，这让人神经紧张。你必须私下，你不必承认这一点，但你必须私下里只是对出去炫耀感到非常兴奋，一点点，因为你在你所做的事情上太该死的好。无论你是在做更新还是做赫格塞斯，我的意思是，这只是，你必须是，我很想看到更多做你的事情。我认为这是我的，
I think it's one of my favorite politician impressions.
Yeah, yeah, it's really funny.
That I can remember in the long,
and I'm not just saying that because you're here, it's so good.
Yeah.
But there is also the added, because I mean,
obviously he's the secretary of war.
And officially, right?
我认为这是我最喜欢的政治家模仿之一。是的，是的，这真的很有趣。我能记得的，在长期的，我不仅仅是因为你在这里才这么说，它太好了。是的。但也有增加的，因为我的意思是，显然他是战争部长。而且是正式的，对吧？
That's official that was passed by.
It's the only country in the world where we call that department,
the Department of War as opposed to Department of Defense.
I think it's fun that we've now let,
they're obviously letting school kids just name departments.
Is that what's going on?
They're just taking letters.
Yeah, war.
那是官方的，那是通过的。这是世界上唯一一个我们称那个部门为战争部而不是国防部的国家。我认为有趣的是，我们现在让，他们显然只是让学童命名部门。这就是正在发生的事情吗？他们只是在拿字母。是的，战争。
You can tell the generals are just like, oh, God.
Yeah.
But is there, to Sean's question, like, is there another layer?
of trepidation as you've been
as much as you're comfortable telling us
has there been pushback in a weird way?
I don't know. I mean, I'm definitely like a little nervous about,
I kind of just think it's not,
你可以看出将军们只是像，哦，天哪。是的。但有没有，对于肖恩的问题，就像，有没有另一层？焦虑，因为你尽可能多地告诉我们，有没有以一种奇怪的方式受到阻力？我不知道。我的意思是，我绝对是，有点紧张，关于，我有点只是认为它不是，
it's such in the scheme of things like probably,
I hope, barely on his radar.
Like it really does feel like there should be bigger issues.
But there's so much satire on SNL politically always has been.
So like, how is this going to make any big huge wave?
people are conditioned to look for satire politically.
I don't know. This guy could end up having a big night.
He's got a couple of cocktails under his belt.
它在事情的计划中，就像希望，几乎在他的雷达上。就像它真的感觉应该有更大的问题。但《周六夜现场》政治上总是有很多讽刺。所以，这怎么会引起任何巨大的波澜？人们被训练去寻找政治上的讽刺。我不知道。这家伙最终可能会有一个大夜晚。他喝了几杯鸡尾酒。
And he might start calling you.
There could be some vindictiveness.
Guess what?
I'll bet he loves it.
I mean, the first time I did it, my brother,
I have a younger brother, my younger brother was like,
it's just so great that America finally gets to see the real you.
Well, that's what I was going to ask.
他可能会开始给你打电话。可能会有一些报复心。猜猜怎么着？我敢打赌他喜欢它。我的意思是，我第一次做的时候，我弟弟，我有一个弟弟，我弟弟当时说，美国终于能看到真实的你，这太棒了。嗯，那正是我要问的。
So, like, you know, what would you like, would you like
to do more, I would love
to see you do more acting,
whether it be on SNL or not.
Is it, is there, do you think you'd ever
carve out some time to do more of that?
Well, you've got a movie coming up.
I would love it. Yeah, this, I'm doing,
所以，就像，你知道，你想要什么，你想要做更多吗，我很想看到你做更多的表演，无论是在《周六夜现场》还是其他地方。是吗，你认为你曾经会抽出一些时间做更多那样的表演吗？嗯，你有一部电影要上映了。我很想。是的，这，我正在做，
I did this movie with Nate,
with Nate Bergetse who I love.
Called the breadwinner.
Breadwinner that's coming out, May 29th.
Yay.
Yay. All right.
And I have, I think I have a fun party.
Like, Nate's basically forced to be
我做了这部电影，和内特，和内特·巴格扎（Nate Bargatze）一起，我爱他。叫《面包赢家》（The Breadwinner）。《面包赢家》，5月29日上映。耶。耶。好的。而且我有，我想我有一个有趣的派对。就像，内特基本上被迫成为
a stay-at-home dad because his wife
goes on Shark Tank and hits,
gets a lot of traction.
And the sharks,
the shark tank scene is so funny.
And it's so,
so funny.
And the sharks basically make Nate agree
一个全职爸爸，因为他的妻子上了《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）并获得了，获得了很大的关注。而且《创智赢家》的场景太有趣了。而且它太，太有趣了。而且鲨鱼们，鲨鱼坦克场景基本上让内特同意
to be a stay-at-home dad,
so is why on camera.
And I'm the only other stay-at-home dad
in the neighborhood,
and I'm really,
I'm really scared he's taking over my territory.
And he's like a really funny dad that comes in.
And it was so,
成为一个全职爸爸，所以妻子在镜头前。而我是邻居中唯一另一个全职爸爸，我真的很，我真的很害怕他接管了我的领地。而且他是一个非常有趣的爸爸，进来了。而且它太，
and I loved the script,
and he sent it to, you know,
I was,
people,
people really think of me for things so i was very grateful they that they thought of me for it and it was
really fun to do and i got to say getting to perform not live is even more liberating because you can
just take swings and you know it's i never get a second chance that thing it's so if you could if you could if you
could if you could if you could wiggle your nose and have uh full success come uh as a writer or as an actor
而且我喜欢这个剧本，他把它发给了，你知道，我当时是，人们，人们真的因为事情想到我，所以我非常感激他们想到我，而且做起来真的很有趣。而且我不得不说，能够进行非现场表演甚至更令人解放，因为你可以只是尝试，你知道，它，我从来没有第二次机会，那件事，所以如果你能，如果你能，如果你能，如果你能，如果你能动动你的鼻子并获得，呃，完全的成功，作为一名编剧或作为一名演员
let's say in the next five or 10 years.
Like, let's say go the route of like, you know,
let's say Will Ferrell or go the route of like Mike Scher.
It's tough, right?
Yeah, good options.
I mean, I would really love to do,
to get to perform in something outside,
you know, a thing that's my own voice and get to create.
让我们说在未来5或10年内。比如，让我们走像，你知道，让我们说威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）的路线，或者走像迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）的路线。这很难，对吧？是的，好的选择。我的意思是，我真的想做，能够表演一些东西，在外面，你知道，一个我自己的声音的东西，并能够创作。
I mean, you know it well.
Like it's, you know, it's, that would be really satisfying.
I think that would be really, really, really,
in the same project?
Yeah, maybe.
I mean, I don't need to be, I don't need to be, I would rather be, get to perform.
Yeah.
But I would like, I would obviously be involved in some way.
我的意思是，你很了解它。就像它是，你知道，它是，那会非常令人满意。我认为那会非常，非常，非常，在同一个项目中？是的，也许。我的意思是，我不需要是，我不需要是，我宁愿是，能够表演。是的。但我想要，我显然会以某种方式参与。
I don't think I would not be able to, but I would like to figure out an idea, maybe ideally both, where it's a world that's my own in my, from my own mind, too.
I would love that.
And to think we almost lost you to Bear Stearns or something like that.
Yeah.
We're doing so much better.
I could be long retired, really.
Exactly.
But what about you also?
我不认为我做不到，但我希望能想出一个点子，最好是两者兼顾，创造一个属于我自己的世界，源于我自己的思想。我会很喜欢那样。想到我们差点因为贝尔斯登之类的公司而失去你，真是……是啊，我们现在过得好多了。说真的，我本来早就该退休了。没错。但你呢？
If you got a Bear Stearns,
it would have been a disaster list.
Oh, yeah.
That was, yeah.
You could have become,
you could, you could have become D's, you know.
Oh, the great Danesies.
It's the great Danubey.
如果你去了贝尔斯登，那绝对是一场灾难。哦，是的。那是……是的。你本可能成为D，你知道的。哦，伟大的丹尼斯（Danesies）。那是伟大的多瑙河（Danubey）。
It's the best.
Colin, you also do pop culture Jeopardy,
which is fantastic.
Wait, is that the one that's on Netflix?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's coming out on Netflix in May 11th.
太棒了。科林，你还主持了《流行文化危险边缘》，那真是太精彩了。等等，是Netflix上那个吗？是的。没错，5月11号在Netflix上线。
Season 2, right?
Yeah, season two, yeah.
It's, it's, it's really fun.
Like, I cannot believe.
the level of knowledge that
these teams have about pop culture.
It's very, it's really scary.
Well, I have a surprise for these guys,
第二季，对吧？是的，第二季。真的非常有趣。我简直不敢相信这些参赛队伍对流行文化的了解程度。太可怕了。好吧，我给这几位准备了一个惊喜，
which is a clip if Bennett can play it or Rob can play it.
Really?
We don't think we've never run a clip before.
We've never done a clip. Let's go to the clip.
Oh, my God.
In a category of So Help Me Pod,
the smartless podcast
is hosted by this trio
如果本内特或罗伯能播放的话，那是一个片段。真的吗？我们好像从来没放过片段。我们从没做过。让我们来看片段。天哪。在“救救我，播客”这个类别里，SmartLess播客是由这三位
of funny guys. Anna Marie.
Who is Sean Hayes?
That is one, Alex.
Who is Eric McCormick?
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Steve.
Who is Will Arnett?
That is the second and Ashley.
搞笑的人主持的。安娜·玛丽。肖恩·海耶斯是谁？那是第一位，亚历克斯。埃里克·麦柯马克是谁？哦，天哪。史蒂夫。威尔·阿奈特是谁？那是第二位，还有阿什利。
Who's Fred Armisen?
That is a person, but no.
Justin?
Who is Hayes?
I'm sorry.
The one we were missing?
Jason Bateman, but the other two
are going to be very happy to throw it in Jason's face.
弗雷德·阿米森是谁？那确实是个人，但不对。贾斯汀？海耶斯是谁？抱歉。我们漏掉的那个人？杰森·贝特曼，但另外两位会很高兴当面嘲笑杰森的。
Got it.
It's going to hurt in the renegotiations, but thanks for running the clip.
So, let's go forward.
I have reactions.
Let's go around the horn.
We'll start with you, Jason.
I thought that was so great.
You know what?
明白了。这在重新谈判合同时会很伤人，但谢谢你们播放片段。那么，继续吧。我有反应了。我们轮流来。从你开始，杰森。我觉得太棒了。你知道吗？
That Jason abatement
started to look pretty good, huh?
Nice.
Bold doesn't sound so bad.
I don't know.
So this was not tournament of champions, I guess.
You know, these weren't the world beaters.
No, these were the most knowledgeable.
那个杰森·贝特曼看起来还不错，对吧？不错。秃头听起来也不坏。我不知道。所以这不是冠军锦标赛，我想。你知道，这些不是世界级的选手。不，这些是最博学的人。
Come on.
Wow.
I think I was the only answer wrong in that whole a game.
Jesus, that cuts deep.
Which you never see.
The point is,
But the point is breadwinner, celebrity, SNL, like all of it.
You have so much going on, and you have kids, and you have scarlet,
得了吧。哇。我想我是整场比赛中唯一答错的人。天哪，那真是扎心。你从没见过这种情况。重点是，重点是养家糊口、名人身份、周六夜现场，所有这些。你有很多事情要忙，你有孩子，你有斯嘉丽，
and you have, like, just a whole, I mean, you have a ton of stuff going on.
Yeah, yeah, you're really, you're kicking into high gear right now,
and it's fun to watch, man.
It's really fun to watch.
It's fun.
I love watching a golf club on top of it all.
I know.
We've threatened to play.
你有很多事情，我是说，你有很多事情在进行。是的，是的，你现在正处于全速前进的状态，看着很有趣，伙计。看着真的很有趣。很有趣。我喜欢看高尔夫俱乐部，而且还要兼顾这一切。我知道。我们一直威胁要一起打球。
We got to, let's do it.
Maybe this summer you'll be out a little bit and we'll do it.
Yeah, I love it.
We're going to be on Long Island.
Do you guys, do you ever do, go to do the Tahoe event or anything like that?
I'm not into the fucking rock and roll
with the boats on the fairway
and fucking what?
我们必须得去，就这样吧。也许今年夏天你会有空，我们去打一场。是的，我很喜欢。我们要去长岛。你们去过太浩湖的活动吗？我不喜欢那种在球道上开着船、放着摇滚乐的疯狂派对，什么鬼？
Well, now he's never going, but...
What's happening?
Unplugged the speakers and what's place.
And he's filthy people in Tahoe.
I just, I don't understand how it's just...
We did, we've done a couple of them before.
We did the, we did the Pebble Beach back in the day.
Now that's a tournament.
好吧，现在他肯定不会去了，但是……怎么了？拔掉音箱，什么地方。太浩湖的人真是太脏了。我只是，我不明白怎么会……我们以前参加过几次。我们以前去过圆石滩。那才叫锦标赛。
That must have been fun, right?
We did that, and we did.
We've done Genesis a few times.
Oh, yeah, because in LA, that's fun.
Yeah, it's in Illinois.
But I started our own golf tournament, you guys.
Yeah, let's do that, you know.
What do you say, Colin?
那一定很有趣，对吧？我们参加过，我们参加过。我们去过几次捷恩斯公开赛。哦，是的，因为在洛杉矶，那很有趣。是的，在伊利诺伊州。但我发起了我们自己的高尔夫锦标赛，伙计们。是的，我们这样做吧，你知道。你觉得呢，科林？
Yeah, just the three of us.
Yeah, we'll play nine.
Out of Long Island?
You know?
I'm in.
Keep it real.
We've taken up so much of your time.
是的，就我们三个。是的，我们打九洞。在长岛？你知道吗？我加入。保持真实。我加入。我们占用你太多时间了。
So much, too much.
We can talk forever to this guy.
This is unbelievable.
Yeah.
I can stay.
I have, like, a lot of time.
Oh, no problem.
Don't even feel like you got to wrap it up.
太多了，太多了。我们可以和这家伙聊上一辈子。这真是不可思议。是的。我可以留下来。我还有很多时间。哦，没问题。别觉得你必须得结束。
I got to go.
I'm going to have dinner with Tommy Hill.
right now that's a true story
talk to him he did in a
Tommy Hilfiger did an event on our Staten Island
ferry I got to hang out with him there
I'm going to talk to right now what I'm going to say is
we drag it out to Sag Harbor
我得走了。我正要和汤米·希尔一起吃晚饭，这是真的，和他谈谈，他在我们的斯塔滕岛渡轮上办过活动，我有幸在那里和他待过，我现在就要去和他谈谈，我要说的是，我们把它拖到萨格港去，
for the summer
right let's start talking about that
that's what every neighbor wants to look up and see an
large orange
all those billionaires they're not going to be mad at that
it's fun it's kitsy
Colin thank you for being here
your pleasure thank you thank you for bringing
过夏天，对吧？让我们开始谈谈这个，那是每个邻居都想抬头看到的东西，一艘巨大的橙色渡轮，那些亿万富翁们不会生气的，这很有趣，很时髦。科林，谢谢你来到这里，不客气，谢谢你带来的……
Sean.
I'm sorry that we were abusive towards you
and your question asking talents.
Oh, please.
Did you get to, were you able to ask our guests
the things you wanted to ask?
There was some other thing.
There's many other things, but that's okay.
肖恩。很抱歉我们对你和你的提问天赋有些粗鲁。哦，拜托。你有没有机会问我们嘉宾你想问的问题？还有别的事情。还有很多其他事情，但没关系。
We'll get it next time.
I'm sorry, Sean.
That's all right.
Will brings out the worst in me.
It's Will's fault.
Okay.
Well, get back to work, Colin.
I know you have a lot of work there with it,
下次再问吧。对不起，肖恩。没关系。威尔总是激发出我最坏的一面。是威尔的错。好吧。回去工作吧，科林。我知道你那里有很多工作，
especially cleaning up that asbestos above your head.
Yeah.
Because I can still see it.
That's amazing.
I'll know what I find.
Thank you, my friend.
Thank you guys very much.
And I would love to play this summer
尤其是清理你头顶上的石棉。是的。因为我还能看到它。太神奇了。我会知道我发现了什么。谢谢你，我的朋友。非常感谢你们。如果你们想的话，我今年夏天很想去打球，
if you guys want to play anytime.
I'm going to hit you up.
We're going to finally do it.
Yes, please.
Okay.
We're going to finally do it.
Bye, guys.
Bye, Colin Joost.
随时都可以。我会联系你的。我们终于要做了。是的，拜托。好的。我们终于要做了。再见，伙计们。再见，科林·乔斯特。
Good to see you.
I'm waving like that's going to register.
Audio wave.
Thanks, dude.
Sean, what a great guest.
What a lovely man and a funny, funny talent.
很高兴见到你。我在挥手，好像那会有用一样。音频波。音频波。音频波。谢谢，伙计。肖恩，真是个伟大的嘉宾。一个可爱的人，一个非常非常有趣的天才。
I really like Colin.
He's such a funny guy.
I really, every time I'm with him, he's just like easy.
Well, but isn't it amazing?
He's the longest, I don't know if you heard in the intro, the longest, what am I saying,
of weekend update, the guy who's been there the longest of anybody.
Longest tenured?
Yeah, a host or something.
我真的很喜欢科林。他真是个有趣的人。每次和他在一起，我都觉得很轻松。但是，这不是很神奇吗？他是最长的，我不知道你在介绍里有没有听到，最长的，我在说什么，周末更新的主持人，他是待得最久的人。任期最长？是的，主持人什么的。
Did you not sleep last night?
What happened?
I'm still catching up.
Is your CPAP hose clogged?
Just purge your.
your hose. Isn't that wild though to just be to know, like he just submitted to SNL.
He's so good. He's so good N-J too and Michael D. Who might don't know?
Yeah, Michael-Jane is hilarious.
你昨晚没睡觉吗？怎么了？我还在补觉。你的呼吸机软管堵了吗？清理一下你的软管。不过，知道他只是提交给《周六夜现场》不是很疯狂吗？他太棒了。他太棒了，还有迈克尔·切。我不认识他？是的，迈克尔·切太搞笑了。
Hilarious. Those guys are so funny.
Yeah.
Wait, what was the joke somebody reminded me of that they did this last weekend?
They played like a clip of Trump saying, you know, look, we're holding all the cards.
And then they come back to colonies like, they're literally holding a straight.
Yes, I saw that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I thought that's a good joke.
太搞笑了。那些家伙太有趣了。是的。等等，有人提醒我他们上周末讲的那个笑话是什么来着？他们播放了一个特朗普说“看，我们掌握着所有的牌”的片段。然后他们切回科林，他说“他们真的拿着顺子”。是的，我看到了。是的，我觉得那是个好笑话。
It was a pun.
It's a pun.
You know, guys, there's a lot of purchases we've all made in our life.
You know, what started out is this.
Good buys and some are bad buys?
Is that what?
Mine.
Okay, so, okay, but you're going to back and do it.
那是个双关语。是个双关语。你知道，伙计们，我们一生中买过很多东西。你知道，最初开始的是这个。好的买卖和坏的买卖？是这样吗？我的。好吧，所以，好吧，但你要回去做这件事。
Well, why don't you give it a little bit of a head, like talk about the fairy?
Yeah, it's a town.
Yeah, it's a bad thing.
Sometimes there's good, you know, purchase.
I mean, yeah, the staten.
What an interesting thing to learn about that he,
what drew him to buy that Staten Island Fair when he was a kid.
You spent it right there.
好吧，你为什么不稍微给点提示，比如谈谈渡轮？是的，那是个城镇。是的，那是一件坏事。有时候有好的，你知道，买卖。我是说，是的，斯塔滕。了解他小时候是什么吸引他买下那艘斯塔滕岛渡轮，真是一件有趣的事情。你刚才说对了。
You can't say buy until the end.
Okay, so still rolling.
Okay.
It was an interesting thing that he purchased that Staten Island Ferry
with Pete Davidson because it brought, you know,
because he took it when he was a kid to go to school.
Yeah.
So, you know, we've all kind of made interesting purchases.
你不能在最后之前说买。好吧，所以还在录。好的。他买下那艘斯塔滕岛渡轮和皮特·戴维森一起是一件有趣的事情，因为它带来了，你知道，因为他小时候坐它去上学。所以，你知道，我们都做过有趣的购买。
Some are good, some are bad.
But that started out as a seemingly,
bad purchase but in the end it was a good
I know what he's good bye
I like this goodbye
I like this goodbye I like this goodbye
I got to take a leak so fucking bad
okay love you think of me when you hold it
有些是好的，有些是坏的。但那最初看起来像是一次糟糕的购买，但最后它是一个好的，我知道他是一个好的买卖，我喜欢这个好的买卖，我喜欢这个好的买卖，我喜欢这个好的买卖，我得去撒尿，太急了，好的，爱你，当你憋着的时候想想我。
smart
smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted
by Michael Grant Terry
Rob Armjav and Bennett
Barbico
smart
less
SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾夫和本内特·巴比科100%有机且手工制作的。SmartLess。